Das ist in einigen Ways sehr anders, als Hacken oder Verbrechen eines Websites.
Ich bin ein Code-Hacker, aber ich hacke keine Websites, keine DDoS-Sites, ich mache nichts illegales, und ich würde meine Frau töten. Ihr hört CRE, Technik, Kultur, Gesellschaft. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und das hier ist Ausgabe Nummer 188 unserer Gesprächsreihe. Und ja, heute tauchen wir mal wieder ein in so ein Thema, wo glaube ich sowohl Technik, Kultur und Gesellschaft eine ziemlich große Rolle spielt. Es soll gehen um eine konkrete Form des netzpolitischen Aktivismus, noch konkreter gesprochen um eine Gruppe namens Telecomix und um darüber mal was zu erfahren, begrüße ich Stephan Urbach. Ja, Stephan, was bist du denn eigentlich für einer? Ich meine, du bist ja auch so einer, der so ein bisschen, soll ich sagen, so ein bisschen ins Netz geboren ist, oder?
Ja und nein. Ich hatte, als ich jung war, viele Rechner gebastelt und gemacht und dann irgendwie fünf Jahre lang gar nicht mehr. Und hab ein anderes Hobby gefunden gehabt, draußen. Und als ich das nicht mehr ausüben konnte, bin ich wieder zurück an den Rechner.
Ja, ich glaube, so eine Pause kann auch mal ganz gut tun. Ich hatte das auch mal.
Ich war völlig schockiert, was Rechner alles plötzlich können.
Gut, aber du bist auch schon relativ früh so mit der Materie zusammengekommen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also, das fing an, dass mein Opa mir irgendwie davon Dinge erzählt hat. Der war Ingenieur und hat von der Zuse geschwärmt. Das hat mein Interesse geweckt. Dann, mein Bruder hatte vor mir einen Rechner, ein C64. Hab ich dann auch gekriegt. Da hat mein Bruder dann einen Amiga 500 gehabt. Den hab ich dann auch gekriegt. Da hat er seinen ersten 286er gehabt. Und dann hab ich mir immer ein Pentium gekauft.
Also Ende 80er, Anfang 90er.
Genau.
Da hat sich das alles abgespielt, wenn ich das richtig sehe.
Genau, dann kam die große Pause. Und dann ging es nachdem ich das Hobby nicht mehr ausüben konnte, wieder weiter mit Rechnern so. Hey, da hab ich dann noch mal Technik gehabt. Guck, ob die noch geht.
Aber war denn das auch gleich von vorne rein so ein politisches Thema für dich?
Nee, das war erst mal vor allem erkennen, was kann Rechner überhaupt. Also früher hab ich viel gespielt. Die alten Adventure, ich liebe sie heute noch. Und erst nach meiner Pause habe ich so richtig begriffen, was Vernetzung eigentlich heißt und was es heißt, irgendwie online zu gehen. Und das war halt dann sehr groß für mich und eine völlig neue Welt.
Was heißt es denn, online zu gehen?
Für online zu gehen heißt es, einen Horizont zu erweitern vor allem. Das heißt es, eine neue Welt zu erreichen, in der man unglaublich viel Kunst, Kultur, Musik und auch Schwachfug finden kann. Und die Mischung macht es halt. Also es ist diese Mischung, die es sehr interessant macht. Ich hatte einen Online-Zugang über CompuSurf, also so einen echt furchtbaren, aber...
Aber auch einen echt frühen.
Das auch, ja. Und habe dann da aber, als dann irgendwann der CompuSurf-Internet-Dialer rauskam, man als echt Internet durfte damit, unglaublich tolle Sachen für mich gefunden. Irgendwie die ersten Foren habe ich entdeckt und konnte mich da dann über Star Trek austauschen und dann auch über andere Dinge. Das war einfach eine neue Welt. Das hat mich aus meinem Dorf rausgelassen, in dem ich gewohnt habe.
Das war auch eins. Das war auch ein richtiges Dorf.
Das war so ein richtiges Dorf, ja. Das war so ein Dorf mit Bauern und Kühen und Traktoren und total geil eigentlich zum Aufwachsen. Viel Felder außenrum. Aber man kommt halt gedanklich nicht raus. Das ist halt doch sehr...
Eingeschränkt.
Und da hat mir das Netz geholfen, erst mal das zu erkennen, dass da draußen noch viel mehr ist als mein Dorf. Ja, das war dann einfach dieser Schritt so, hey, das ist wichtig, das funktioniert und das ist großartig.
Und es gibt Gleichgesinnte.
Das kommt noch schwer hinzu. Die haben die gleichen verrückten Hobbys wie man selbst. Damals alter Rollenspieler. Auf dem Dorf, oh mein Gott. Das ist doch der Verrückte. Sie hatten nicht ganz unrecht, aber das muss man ja nicht sagen. Ich hatte dann E-Mail-Bekannschaften. Vorher hatte ich Brieffreunde, dann hatte ich E-Mails. Man hat sich E-Mails hin- und hergeschickt. Heute kriegt man ja kaum noch eine lange E-Mail. Heute macht man das ja irgendwie.
Brieffreundschaften, das gab es ja auch vor dem Internet.
Ja, genau, hatte ich ja auch.
Nur, dass man das normalerweise eben zu Papier gebracht hat.
Genau, und heute habe ich übrigens wieder Brieffreundschaften.
Ja, das ist dieser Retro-Effekt, ne?
Naja, vor allem so hinsetzen und einen Brief schreiben, ist was völlig anderes als eine E-Mail tippen.
Das stimmt, das stimmt. Womit schreibst du dann?
Mit der Hand und einem Füller.
Mit einem Füller, das wollte ich wissen.
Auf Briefpapier. Aber den Füller habe ich seit meiner Banklehre.
Also dann hat dich das Internet befreit und dann hast du eine Banklehre gemacht?
Ne, vorher habe ich studiert Deutsch und Geschichte auf Lehramt für Gymnasium und habe das dann sein lassen, weil ich arbeiten musste. Dann habe ich im Reimeingebiet, wo ich herkomme, eine Banklehre gemacht zum Bank- und Sparkassenkaufmann. Und habe dann auch in dem Beruf gearbeitet. Und habe dann immer gesagt, fuck it, ich gehe jetzt zu AOL. Und habe dann bei AOL gearbeitet.
Warum nicht bei der Bank?
Die bezahlt schlechter. Also so als frisch genannte Bank.
Also so schlechter als AOL sozusagen.
Die zahlt auch schlechter als AOL. Und AOL zahlt schon nicht so gut.
Damals zumindest, ne?
Heute zahlen die immer noch nicht wirklich besser. Also das wird auch nicht wirklich besser mehr, glaube ich. Ich glaube, AOL hat eh noch vielleicht drei bis vier Jahre.
Okay, also du bist dann sozusagen ins Internet abgetaucht. Aber war dir dann zu dem Zeitpunkt schon irgendwie klar, dass das Netz für dich auch so eine politische Dimension darstellt? Oder ist das einfach nur so ein Ding, wo man super seine Brieffreundschaften pflegen kann?
Das war erst mal nur ein Ding, wo man seine Brieffreundschaften pflegen kann und Rollenspiele spielen kann. Bis dann 1996 Felix Zomm verurteilt worden ist von CompuServe. Dieses unsägliche Urteil in München damals, wo Felix Zomm wegen dem Zugang zu kinderpornografischen Schriften verurteilt worden ist, den ein Nutzer über CompuServe hatte.
Und Felix Zomm selber war Mitarbeiter bei CompuServe?
Das war der Geschäftsführer von CompuServe Deutschland. Und der wurde dann verknackt dafür. Selbst der Staatsanwalt hat auf Freispruch plädiert. Und der Richter hat das aber alles irgendwie nicht gelten lassen und hat den dann verknackt. Und das war halt völlig bizarr. Also das hatte ich in meinem Rechtsverständnis überhaupt nicht verstanden, wie der Mensch, der nur die Infrastruktur baut, das ich damals auch überhaupt nicht so genannt habe, für das, was andere Leute damit tun, bestraft werden kann. Das war aber so der erste Schritt, wo ich dachte, da läuft was schief, da passt was nicht. Gut, ich war 16, hatte bunte Haare. Und hatte dann irgendwie linksanarchistische Ansichten damals noch. Das hat aber irgendwie zum ersten Mal richtig gezeigt, hey, da läuft was schief. Also das war für mich ein völliger Skandalurteil. Sehe ich auch heute noch als Skandalurteil an. Es hat ein Leben zerstört von diesem Herrn Somm. Und das war so ein erster Berührungspunkt mit Politik und Netz. Das war das erste Mal, dass ich da diese Verknüpfung gemerkt habe. Und dann in NRW die Sperrverfügung, die kam ja kurz darauf, die ersten. Auch, was machen die da? Das geht doch nicht, was die da tun. Das ist doch alles kaputt. Das funktioniert so nicht. Und da fing ich an, mir auch Gedanken über das Netz zu machen. Und dann hatte ich halt dieses andere Hobby plötzlich.
Über das wir jetzt nicht reden werden?
Nein, das ist auch für mich nicht spannend.
Nicht relevant?
Nein, das ist nicht relevant. Und hab dann auch da natürlich über Netzpolitik und dergleichen nichts mitbekommen. Und im Endeffekt richtig tief wieder eingestiegen bin ich in das netzpolitische Ding, auch mit Zinsos oder wie viele andere auch. Ich hab halt vorher zu Hause auf lokaler Ebene versucht, Jugendpolitik mit zu gestalten und dann kam ja, Frau von der Leyen mit ihren Sperrideen. Und das hat mich dann endgültig wieder politisiert, also auch was Netzpolitik betrifft. Weil bis dahin war auch das Netz für mich ein Werkzeug. Also ich hab's viel benutzt als Werkzeug und plötzlich hat man...
Das heißt, es will einem jemand das Werkzeug wegnehmen?
Genau. Und das hat mich dann also endgültig wieder politisiert.
Aber jetzt hast du ja da so ein bisschen so eine weitere Karriere eingeschlagen, indem du mit anderen Leuten zusammengekommen bist, die dann später die Gruppe Telecomix ausgerufen haben oder hieß es schon so, als du dazukamst?
Als ich dazukam, hießen sie schon so.
Wo ist das gestartet?
In Schweden.
Wie so häufig.
Wie so häufig kommen die tollen Sachen aus Schweden. In Gothenburg bei einer Konferenz sagte ein, ich hab den Namen vergessen, ein Vortragende, jemand müsste mal eine Gruppe gründen, die Netzpolitik gestalten will. Und dann haben es halt welche gemacht.
Wobei es ja nicht so war, dass es jetzt keine Gruppen gegeben hätte, die versucht haben, Netzpolitik zu gestalten.
Ja, es ging aber in Deutschland. Ja, aber in Schweden. Das ist ziemlich leer gewesen.
Ach so, Gothenburg in Schweden?
Gothenburg in Schweden, ja. Gothenburg.
Alles klar, ich dachte jetzt schon.
Und da haben sich dann die Jungs und Mädels zu Telecomix zusammengeschlossen und haben angefangen mit Netzpolitik in Schweden und auf Europaebene. Damals das Telecom-Paket, iPred und solche Dinge, und da haben, es wurde analysiert, es wurden von den Gruppenmitgliedern, was da eigentlich drinsteht, was das für Implikationen hat. Es wurde Abgeordnete mitgeteilt, Ministerien wurden angeschrieben. Und es war so ein politischer Körper. Und ich bin im Zuge meiner Recherchen zu ACTA, dem Anti-Counterfighting Trade Agreement, auf Telecomix gestoßen. Und bin dann da hängen geblieben. Weil damit haben wir uns auch beschäftigt bei Telecomix mit ACTA. Das haben wir auch auseinandergenommen, haben versucht, Dokumente zu finden, haben uns die Leaks genau angeschaut, haben die Diffs gemacht dazu zwischen verschiedenen Versionen. Und war einfach großartig, weil wenn es nicht um Kritik ging, ging es um Kätzchen.
Aber wie hat sich das dann, wenn sich die Gruppe in Schweden gebildet hat, dann wird sie sich ja doch vor allem auf Schweden konzentriert haben.
Ja, schwedisch und europäischen Netzpolitik. Das war schon immer ein offener Körper, also eine offene Gruppe. Im IRC-Server gab es einen Chatraum drauf, und das war der Telecomix-Raum. Und der stand immer offen für jeden. Also wird auch nicht einfach jemand zurückgewiesen. Nee, du darfst nicht. Das ist eine ganz offene Gruppe.
Du darfst nicht was?
Nicht mitmachen, kennt man ja oft genug. Ist bei uns nicht. Darf jeder mitmachen.
Wie muss man sich jetzt diese Organisation vorstellen? Also wie viele Leute tun da real was? Meistens ist es doch so, dass es dann doch immer an sehr wenigen hängen bleibt.
Es hängt an sehr wenigen momentan. Jetzt ganz akut mit Syrien sind beschäftigt so vielleicht 8-10 Leute. Und mit allem außen rum vielleicht noch 15 weitere.
Warum heißen die eigentlich so? Telecomix klingt ja jetzt nicht unbedingt das erste, woran ich denken würde, wäre Netzpolitik, wenn überhaupt.
Ich habe nicht die geringste Ahnung, warum Telecomix so heißt.
Also man hat einfach den Namen toll gefunden.
Ich vermute fast, hat irgendjemand irgendwelche Pilze gegessen.
Ja gut, lassen wir das offen. Aber du bist jetzt quasi einfach über IRC zugestoßen. Jeder war eingeladen und hat gesagt, was ihr macht, finde ich interessant. Und dann war sozusagen ACTA, also dieses geplante, weitgehend geheim gehaltene internationale Handelsabkommen zur Verfolgung von einem möglichen Urheberrechts- und Markenrechtsklimbim, was ja immer noch drohend im Raum steht. Was heißt, ihr habt da Dokumente zusammengetragen? Ich meine, die Dokumente waren ja in dem Sinne, zwar ja weitgehend nicht öffentlich, also es wird ja da extrem versucht, die Dinge geheim zu halten. Wo kriegt man dann diese Dokumente her?
Man kriegt die Dokumente von Leuten, die für die verschiedenen Delegationen arbeiten. Also wir haben damals schon Leaks veröffentlicht. Wir haben andere Leak-Quellen gefunden und dann halt die Dokumente auch verglichen. Es gab, glaube ich, bis heute, ich glaube 50 verschiedene Versionen des Vertrags. Also des Akta-Vertrags. Und immer wenn eine neue größere Leak kam, haben wir halt dann die Diffs gemacht. Was hat sich geändert zwischen den vorherigen Versionen? Meistens war es halt nach diesen Runden, wo sich die Unterhändler getroffen hatten, kam meistens irgendwo wieder ein Leak einer größeren Version raus. Und wir haben es dann immer wieder neu analysiert, neue Kritik formuliert, Abgeordnete angeschrieben auf europäischer Ebene, den verschiedenen Nationalstaaten, auch die mexikanischen Abgeordneten haben wir angeschrieben. Wir hatten damals noch viele mexikanische Mitglieder auch. Bei Mexiko ist es ein durchaus größeres Thema als in Deutschland. Warum? Weil da eine ganze Industrie hinten dran hängt. Die ACTA haben wir also auch ganz offen dafür wirbt für ACTA, weil in Mexiko ist die größte Seifenoper-Produktion in spanischer Sprache. Ja. Also in Mexiko werden die meisten spanischsprachigen Seifenopern erstellt. Und die Sendekonzepte werden einfach nachgedreht. Also es gibt einfach dann in anderen spanischsprachigen Ländern einfach Firmen, die das nachdrehen, weil es billiger ist, als die Lizenz zu kaufen. Mit ACTA könnte man das erfolgreich oder erfolgreicher verfolgen.
Ja, verstehe.
Und deswegen will die mexikanische Regierung ACTA haben und hat da sehr extrem, sehr krass dafür Arbeit betrieben, auch mit Werbekampagnen dafür. Und dadurch hätten halt auch viele Mexikaner.
Okay, das heißt, Telecomix hat sich eigentlich mehr eines Themas angenommen und es dann soweit internationalisiert, wie das Thema es verlangt hat. Jetzt gar nicht so sehr, dass man sich so als schwedische Gruppe verstanden hat oder primär so als europäische Gruppe, sondern es gab halt einfach nur diese diese Feststellung aus einer schwedisch- europäischen Perspektive, dass jetzt hier was im Busche ist, wo man jetzt sozusagen nicht einverstanden ist und dann verfolgt man das und trägt das aber dann im Zweifelsfall sogar in andere Kontinente hinein.
Ja, und das funktioniert auch sehr gut eigentlich. Also wir sind gut vernetzt mittlerweile.
Das heißt, eigentlich hat sich die Gruppe extrem schnell verinternationalisiert.
Ja, also es waren wirklich, bei der Gründung waren das irgendwie fünf, sechs Schweden, und das ist halt nicht mehr so. Also das ist, die sind zwar immer noch da, aber es sind nicht die einzigen.
Und gibt es da irgendwie so eine Entscheidungsstruktur? Gibt es da irgendwie, ich meine, das ist immer das Problem, wenn so Gruppen aus ihrer ursprünglichen Struktur heraus wachsen und dann Leute, nicht wahr, Macht, im Anführungsstrichen, delegieren sollen, oder zumindest Entscheidungen und Strategien und diese Entscheidung darüber, was machen wir eigentlich, welche Mittel heißen wir gut, was sind so unsere Methoden etc. Das ist ja dann eigentlich immer genau der Moment, wo es extrem schwierig wird für solche Gruppen.
Das ist auch bei uns hin und wieder schwierig. Wir sind eine Duocracy. Wer Macht hat Recht. Aber immer nur im Rahmen von dem, was die Idee Telecomix vorgibt. Die Idee ist, dass wir für freie Meeresauswohnung kämpfen, dass wir für ein zensurfreies Netz kämpfen und dass wir alles gewaltfrei machen. Wir würden auch niemals zu Gewalt aufrufen mit einer Aktion. Das ist halt die Idee Telecomix. Wir lassen uns nicht von Parteien vereinnahmen. Wir lassen uns nicht von NGOs vereinnahmen dafür. Die Versuche gab es durchaus. Wir werden nicht anfangen zu sagen, dass irgendjemand der Chef oder Leiter von Telecomix ist. Den gibt es nämlich nicht. Es ist ein ISC-Kanal, der das entscheidet. Man diskutiert über ein Thema. Ich habe hier eine Idee. Ich bringe die jetzt ein. Dann diskutiert man drüber und macht einen neuen Kanal auf, um es darin auszuarbeiten, damit der Hauptkanal nicht zuspammt. Dann kommen Leute mit und helfen. Oder es ist eine schlechte Idee. Man ist allein in dem Channel und kann es vergessen.
Das hat natürlich auch Vorteile, weil man auch gleich merkt, ob man einen Mitstreiter findet.
Genau. Wir sind dadurch recht schnell und flexibel. Wir können recht schnell reagieren. Das ist unser Vorteil. Wir sind schnell.
Was heißt schnell? Wie schnell geht das? Hast du mal ein Beispiel für eine neue Idee, die einen neuen Kanal erfordert hat und wo dann auch Leute bereit waren, in einem weiteren Kanal mit zu diskutieren?
Ja, das war als das Netz in Ägypten abgeschaltet worden ist und wir keine Nachrichten mehr bekommen haben aus Ägypten.
Also jetzt Anfang 2011.
Genau.
Der Arabische Frühling, wie er noch genannt wird.
Es ist ja bald schon Winter.
Ja gut, aber wir alle wissen, was los war. Wobei jetzt in Tunesien ging es ja eigentlich los. Also Tunesien hatte in dem Sinne noch keine Auswirkungen gehabt?
Nein, noch nicht, weil da haben wir noch Informationen bekommen. Da haben wir Nachrichten reingetragen, zu uns rübergeschwappt. Man konnte es verfolgen, wunderbar. Tunesische Blogger konnten sich austauschen. Also Informationen sind geflossen. Das war in Ägypten ja nicht mehr der Fall. Da hat der Mubarak, in einem Anfall von Wahn, gemeint, ich schalte jetzt mal das Netz ab. Lass es abschalten. Und es war halt tot. Da kam halt nichts mehr aus Ägypten raus, seine Informationen.
Wir reden jetzt konkret über den Moment, wo sie der Meinung waren gegen diese Proteste auf dem Tarierplatz und in anderen Teilen Ägyptens und Kairos natürlich auch. Jetzt müssen wir quasi die Kommunikation vollständig unterbinden. Und da uns nichts besseres einfällt, wie wir das irgendwie kontrollieren sollen, schalten wir es einfach ganz ab.
Genau, das war der Plan. Also, vorher ist schon das Handy jetzt abgeschaltet worden.
Aber war denn jemand von euch zu dem Zeitpunkt wirklich auch dran an diesen Informationen? Ich meine, okay, Tunesien, man hat das so beobachtet. Habt ihr es auch wirklich schon jetzt als Gruppe verfolgt? Oder gab es einfach nur so Einzelne, die es interessant fanden?
Wir haben es als Gruppe verfolgt und haben die Nachrichten auch aggregiert und weiterverteilt. Haben Quellen zu den Nachrichten auch gesucht. Also, wir finden ja Quellen immer total wichtig. Also nicht einfach nur Überhauptungen rausschmeißen, sondern die Quelle dazu, sei es ein Video, sei es ein Fernsehbeitrag, ein Blogbeitrag, was auch immer. Und das ging halt nicht mehr. Und dann haben wir diskutiert, was machen wir? Das Netz ist weg. Und dann kamen wir auf die Idee, machen wir das mit Modems. Lass uns Modem-Dial-in-Points bauen. Kurz darüber gesprochen, klingt gut, neue Kanal aufgemacht, rein. Über die Konfiguration gesprochen, technische Details, wie machen wir das jetzt? Und dann vier Stunden später lief der nächste, lief der erste Server, auf dem man sich über ein Telefonnummer einwählen konnte. Also das war...
Quasi wie in den guten alten Zeiten. In den guten alten Zeiten. Man nimmt das ja gar nicht mehr so sehr wahr. Internet kommt aus der Dose. Und zwar mehr oder weniger direkt. Man muss da zwar noch was ranbammeln, aber es ist nicht so wie früher, dass man erst mal den Weg über das Telefonnetz suchen muss, sondern der Internet-Anteil im Telefonnetz hat sich so weit schon an einen herangekrochen, dass es irgendwie immer da ist. Und man hat vor allem, auch wenn das jetzt technisch natürlich auf der niedrigsten Ebene nach wie vor so ist, man muss sich in dem Sinne nicht mehr einwählen. Also man kann zumindest üblicherweise sein Netz einfach immer anhaben. Genau. Das war ja vor einigen Jahren noch eine völlig absurde Idee. Also für manche war das eine völlig absurde Idee. Für mich war das persönlich jetzt noch nie eine absurde Idee. Aber man gewöhnt sich ja schnell daran. Ihr habt quasi wieder die 90er-Jahre aufgerufen. Zumal es natürlich jetzt nicht so ist, dass in Ägypten überall DSL existiert.
Ne, in Ägypten existiert viel ESDN, aber auch noch viel analoge Leitungen.
Das heißt, die Leute hatten diese Modems ohnehin und haben sich eigentlich lokal eingewählt.
Die haben wir auch fast alle noch. Und zwar, wenn unser Notebook nicht älter als ein halbes Jahr, dreiviertel Jahr ist, hat es noch meistens, außer das ist von Apple, eine Modem-Dose hinten dran. Wenn ich heute einen Dell-Laptop kaufe, hat das immer noch einen Modem dran.
Wirklich? Gute Güte.
Das ist die Dose, die keiner benutzt.
Aber das muss man sich jetzt auch mal klar machen. Also da war es sozusagen auch noch nicht nur jetzt vorhanden. Es war jetzt nicht nur eingebaut, sondern auch im aktiven Gebrauch.
Genau, in Benutzung.
Sodass sich eigentlich für die Leute in dem Moment das nur soweit geändert hat, dass sie eine andere Telefonnummer anrufen.
Ja, aber die mussten wir auch runterbringen, die Nummern.
Genau, das wäre meine nächste Frage gewesen. Ich meine jetzt alleine unseren Server irgendwo aufzusetzen und wie bringt man jetzt in ein Land, was kein Internet hat, diese Nachricht?
Naja, sie haben Faxgeräte. Und wir können faxen.
Und wohin habt ihr es dann gefaxen?
Wir haben aus dem Google-Cache Nummern von Elektro-Läden, Computer-Läden, Bibliotheken, wissenschaftlichen Instituten, Hotels, und einfach wild gestreut. Und oben drauf eine to whom it may concern. Und haben es verteilt.
Das heißt, ihr habt einfach so eine DIN-A4-Seite mit der Information. Auch übrigens, falls ihr gerade zu wenig Internet habt, ihr könnt da ja mal anrufen und so weiter.
Da gibt es welches.
Und das sind hier eure Login-Parameter. Tra la la.
Genau.
Muss man da auch ein Passwort angeben?
Ja, schon drauf. Passwort Telecomix. Username Telecomix. War recht einfach.
Okay.
Und wir hatten auch alle aufgerufen, die uns auch da bereitstellen wollen, diese Usernamen-Passwort-Kombination zu benutzen. So dass wir nachher einfach eine lange Liste Nummern hatten und drunter einmal die Login-Daten.
Und wart ihr jetzt, habt ihr irgendwelche Erkenntnisse, ob ihr da wirklich die ersten wart, die das getan haben? Gab es noch andere Einwahlpunkte, die jetzt von anderen Gruppen gleichem Maße bereitgestellt wurden?
Wir waren die ersten wohl. Also wenn man auch danach googelt nach Modems und Ägypten, kommt eigentlich nur Telecomix und dann noch das FDN, das French Data Network. Das sind ein paar Jungs aus Paris, die betreiben eigentlich einen bulletproof Hosting. Also die interessieren sich nicht für Hidopi zum Beispiel. Die haben dann auch noch ihren Modempool freigegeben und haben uns die Nummer mit verteilen lassen. Die haben sich aufgrund unserer Aktion da angeschlossen. Genauso wie der Provider VXS, XS4ALL aus den Niederlanden, der hat das auch gemacht, und der Verein free.de aus dem Ruhrpott. Die haben auch ihren Modempool hochgefahren und uns die Einwahldaten gegeben.
Es ist ja schon mal gut zu wissen, dass es diese Modempools überhaupt noch gibt.
Ja, sie fressen unglaublich viel Strom und ich will die keiner mehr betreiben.
Aber wirklich?
Also so eine Maschine, wo die ganzen Modempools drin sind, das ist 20 Jahre alte Technologie. Stromsparen ist nicht wirklich angebracht gewesen. Und unglaublich teuer im Betrieb. Plus ein Multiplex-Anschluss, gibt es momentan nur die Telekom, die das macht, also die mehrfach analogen Leitungen auf einem Anschluss legen, die kosten unglaublich viel Geld.
Ja, aber man muss ja jetzt, also in Deutschland braucht man ja keinen analogen Anschluss, um analoge Anrufe entgegenzunehmen. Man kann das ja auch genauso wie ISDN machen.
ISDN nicht mit Multiplex-Anschluss, nicht richtig gut. Also es ist mit analogen Anschluss echt besser.
Weil es da nicht die entsprechende Hardware für gibt?
Ja, es gibt ISDN-Einwahl-Punkte.
Man kann darüber auch dann, ok, das muss natürlich auch entsprechend bestückt sein.
Genau.
Und was für eine Kapazität habt ihr jetzt konkret so bereitstellen können? Also wie viele Einwahlleitungen konntet ihr gleichzeitig bereitstellen?
300 Stück. 300 Stück. Das ist nicht so viel für ein Land.
Das ist schonmal ganz ordentlich. Genau. Das umfasst jetzt auch XS4ALL und die anderen?
Genau, das umfasst die auch dazu.
Also alles, was sich daran beteiligt hat.
Genau, also XS4ALL und FDN hatten zusammen, ich glaube, 80 Leitungen knapp, plus die 20 aus dem Pod, also 200 von Privatpersonen ungefähr.
Private Leute, die dann einfach gesagt haben, ich hab auch noch eine Leitung, warum nicht?
Genau, gebe ich her.
Und gibt es irgendwelche Erkenntnisse darüber, wie viele davon auch gleichzeitig genutzt wurden?
Wir haben eine Philosophie bei Telecomix, nicht zu loggen, außer am Anfang, um zu prüfen, ob die Dinge funktionieren. Das FDN konnte sie nicht abschalten. Die haben gesagt, das waren zu 85% ägyptische Nummern, die bei ihnen angerufen haben. Also die Nummern waren ja öffentlich, konnte ja jeder benutzen.
Jaja, klar.
Aber zu 85% waren es ägyptische Nummern. Und ich hab auch einen Server betrieben. Das waren auch die ersten 10 Anrufe, hab ich mir angeguckt, wer das denn macht. Das waren auch überwiegend Ägypter. Kleiner Spaß am Rande, einer hat es dann auch für den Hauer mit dem Wasser runtergeladen. Ich vermute, Tom Klein war noch an im Hintergrund. Aber ich fand das gut. Und ja, also das insgesamt war schon eine überwiegende Nutzung durch ägyptische Bürgerinnen und Bürger da.
Okay. Aber was ist jetzt dein Gefühl, wie viele Leute davon wirklich real Nutzen gezogen haben?
Real Nutzen gezogen haben davon, ich glaube, fast jeder, der es benutzen konnte, denn er war in dem Augenblick wieder frei zu sagen, was er möchte, egal zu wem. Und als Beispiel, was mich am meisten getroffen hatte, also auf einer emotionalen Ebene, war die Mail, nachdem das ganze Kack da vorbei war in Ägypten, von einem jungen Mann, der uns ein Dankes-E-Mail schrieb, dass er über unsere Infrastruktur seinen Eltern in London eine E-Mail schreiben konnte, dass es ihm gut geht. Und dafür haben wir das gemacht, genau dafür.
Was war denn so euer Eindruck? Ich meine, es gab ja, und gibt auch immer noch, was diese ganze arabische Revolution, insbesondere die in Ägypten betrifft, viele Diskussionen darüber, welchen Anteil das Internet an diesem Aufstand gehabt hat. Wie schätzt du das ein?
Ich habe da eine gespaltene Meinung. Einerseits, wenn ich das möchte, ich es gern glauben, weil man es gern glauben möchte. Andererseits habe ich aus den Gesprächen mit den Leuten einfach festgestellt, also in Ägypten sind sie, nachdem das Netz aus war, sind die Leute aus ihren Häusern raus, weil sie sauer waren, weil sie das Netz wieder haben wollten. Also es war nicht mehr vorhanden, sie konnten nicht mehr online gehen, sie waren sauer und sind deswegen noch mehr auf den Tagierplatz geströmt.
Also sozusagen eher der Entzug des Internets. Na gut, aber bis zu dem Zeitpunkt gab es ja schon den Protest.
Genau, den Protest gab es schon.
Und es ist halt auch die Frage, hätte sich dieser Protest so überhaupt finden können? Also ich denke, so eine der Thesen, die im Raum stehen sind, ist ja ganz unzweifelhaft, dass es schon immer viel Unzufriedenheit gegeben hat mit der Ist-Situation. Und das mag viele Jahrzehnte zurückgehen, nur das Problem ist, man stellt sich halt erst gegen das, was einen unterdrückt, wenn man das Gefühl hat, dass genug andere mitziehen und derselben Meinung sind. Und natürlich ist ein Teil einer Staatspropaganda oder welcher Propaganda auch immer, immer dieses Gefühl aufrechtzuerhalten, alle sind dafür, alle geht's gut, hier gucke mal, Nationaler Feiertag, 100.000 Leute in der Straße, alle jubeln und halten irgendwie das Gesicht unseres lieblichen Führers hoch und so. Und auch wenn man irgendwie weiß, dass da irgendwie Druck dahinter ist, du kannst ja halt nicht direkt ausrechnen, wie viele sind jetzt hier gezwungen und wie viele sind vielleicht wirklich einfach so hirngewaschen, dass sie da einfach mitziehen. Und ich denke, dass es dazu beigetragen haben mag, die Nutzung von Facebook und anderen sozialen Netzwerken, also generell einfach diese Kommunikation mit Internet, so wie du das ja mit dem Dorf vorhin auch so schön geschindert hast. Du machst, du schaltest das Internet ein, du bist irgendwie in der Kommunikation und auf einmal merkst du, da draußen sind ja noch Leute, die denken ja genauso wie ich, ich bin ja gar nicht so anders. Und in gewisser Hinsicht kann ich mir sehr gut vorstellen, ich weiß es nicht, aber ich kann mir sehr gut vorstellen, dass es so eine ähnliche Katalysatorfunktion grundsätzlich in den letzten Jahren gegeben hat mit dem Netz. Und dass es eben jetzt nur zu so einer Kulmination kam.
Also ja, die gibt es, aber natürlich, die Menschen tauschen sich aus. Wenn wir uns gucken in Ägypten, die Aufstände sind vor allem wegen der Korruption entstanden. Also nicht mal gegen den Präsidenten, sondern wegen der Korruption.
Im System.
Im System an sich. Die ersten Transformationen auf Unterheerplatz waren Anti-Korruptions-Demos. Das hat sich dann gewandelt, als unter anderem ein junges Mädchen von Sicherheitskräften vom Platz gezerrt worden ist und der Seitengasse geschlagen worden ist. Sie da auch für ein Video online stellte, wo sie sich laut drüber beschwerte, dass keiner der Männer da war, sie zu beschützen. Und sie und ihre zwei Freundinnen gehen morgen wieder demonstrieren und wenn sie echte Männer sind, kommen sie mit und passen auf sie auf. Ja, also solche Botschaften verbreiten sich halt schnell oder schneller. Diese virale Effekte haben wir jetzt endlich. Es ist halt keine Facebook-Revolution im Sinne, wie es auf Promo geht, sondern es ist einfach eine Nachrichtenrevolution. Die Leute können Nachrichten austauschen. Die Plattform ist aber erstmal völlig egal. In dem Fall ist es halt Facebook, weil das können die Leute bedienen. Wir haben es halt als Nerds nicht hinbekommen, einfach mal schönere oder bessere Plattformen zu bauen, die man benutzen kann. Wenn ich einer von denen werde, würde ich auch das benutzen, was ich verstehe, was ich bedienen kann.
Wobei ich jetzt nicht sagen würde, dass Facebook nicht unbedingt, dass da keine Nerds beteiligt gewesen sind. Man könnte auch sagen, Facebook ist das erste, was die Nerds mal hinbekommen haben, das alle benutzen. Ich würde sogar sagen, es ist das zweite. Das andere ist nämlich auch schon genannt, das war seinerzeit dieses AOL. AOL ist seinerzeit auch genauso ausgeboot worden von den Eingesessenen, hier Internet für die Dummen und so. Aber die Dummen waren dann halt doch sehr glücklich, weil auf einmal war nicht mehr alles so furchtbar technisch und super kompliziert, sondern eigentlich war auch da der Ansatz das gleiche. Man präsentiert so quasi ein integriertes Portal, wo die wesentlichen Kommunikationsfunktionen, sprich hier Mail, Forum, Chat, etc. alles irgendwie mit drin ist. Und es geht dann halt. Und dass man dann nicht wahrnimmt, dass das Internet theoretisch noch mehr bereitstellt, wenn man doch schon eigentlich alles hat. Das ist ja auch nachvollziehbar.
Das gleiche Problem haben wir mit Facebook ja heute auch. Aber das ist, glaube ich, auch eine andere Diskussion.
Ja gut, das geht natürlich hier schon mit rein. Und das auch einfach, weil man ist immer schnell dabei, bei Facebook so eine negative Konnotation mitschwingen zu lassen, wenn es jetzt hier um die eingefleischten Netzbenutzer geht.
Mein Problem ist einfach nur, dass wir es nicht schaffen, das Netz so zu gestalten, dass man eben gerade nicht mehr so ein geschlossenes System wie Facebook oder OAL braucht. Das ist das, was mich immer stört. Dass wir es nicht schaffen, das nicht bedienbar zu machen für die meisten Menschen. Das ist meine Kritik an dem ganzen.
Die teile ich auch voll.
Das freut mich. Auch so ein Foren-System ist nicht trivial zu bedienen, nach wie vor nicht. Und das ist halt in Facebook einfach gelöst. Da funktioniert es.
Genau.
Punkt. Und ja, das ist halt... Also es hätte jedes System sein können, das einen breiter Tand genießt, wo ich Nachrichten austauschen kann. Also momentan ist es halt Facebook, deswegen haben sie es benutzt. Die cooleren Kids haben dann Twitter benutzt. Und das ist halt wirklich so. Das sind die cooleren Kids gewesen, die Twitter benutzt haben. Um halt auch dann schnell Nachrichten auszutauschen, wenn man sich Bilder anschaut, auf dem da hier Platz, die haben Laternen aufgebrochen, um dann in den Strom ranzukommen, ihre Handys zu laden.
Stimmt, das sind ja quasi alles potenzielle Steckdosen.
Das sind alles potenzielle Steckdosen und es gibt auch da Elektriker, die nochmal schnell eine Steckdose draus gebaut haben.
Ich fange gerade ganz anders an, über Laternen nachzudenken.
Das ist wundervoll, Laternen. In Berlin sind die aber doppelt gesichert.
Ja, ich mach mir auch keine Hoffnung, um ehrlich zu sein. Gut, aber wie ist denn das jetzt mit Telecomix weitergegangen? Also ihr habt jetzt diesen Modern Pool bereitgestellt und ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass das dann auch so für die Gruppe selbst auch erstmal ein sehr sinnliches Erlebnis gewesen sein dürfte.
Es war erstmal halt spannend, wir haben Leute online gebracht und dann haben wir uns überlegt, was haben wir eigentlich gerade getan? Also dann haben wir uns erst mal überlegt, was haben wir gerade eigentlich getan? Wir haben uns mit einer Regierung angelegt. Wir haben gesagt, nee, sorry, läuft nicht. Was ihr da macht, finden wir doof. Und deswegen greifen wir in eure Staatssouveränität ein und ändern das. Zu anderen Zeiten wäre das ein kriegerischer Akt gewesen, glaube ich.
Ja.
In einem anderen Land.
Ich glaube, es gibt auch noch einige Länder, mit denen das auch noch schnell ein kriegerischer Akt werden könnte.
Ja, aber das war im Endeffekt das, was wir getan haben. Haben wir gemeint, okay, ist jetzt halt so, weitermachen. Leuten weiterhin Aufklärung geben, weil wir uns war nicht klar, wenn das Netz wieder da ist, was passiert dann? Ist das Netz dann überwacht oder nicht? Wie frei können danach die Leute kommunizieren? Also haben wir Hautos geschrieben. Wie benutze ich Tor zum Beispiel? Wie kann ich sicher kommunizieren? Was ist PGP? Wie benutze ich das?
Gab es denn eigentlich irgendwelche konkreten Abwehrmaßnahmen seitens der Ägypter? Also ich meine, nachdem sie das Netz abgeschaltet haben, ist denen irgendwie, ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass denen das auch jetzt nicht entgangen ist, dass ihr überall Faxe hingeschickt habt.
Ich glaube schon. Ich glaube, sie haben es nicht begriffen, was sie eigentlich getan haben. Weil beim nächsten Land dann, das gerät uns, beim nächsten Land haben sie unsere Einwahlnummern gesperrt. Und das war in Libyen. Da wurden unsere Nummern gesperrt. Es ging nicht.
Und da waren schon alle von vornherein gesperrt? Also waren es dann dieselben Nummern eigentlich wieder?
Dieselben Nummern waren gesperrt. Wir haben dann einige Nummern wechseln können. Das ist aber nicht trivial, mal die Nummer zu wechseln. Geht auch nicht schnell. Die waren dann nicht gesperrt, aber ansonsten waren unsere Nummern gesperrt. Und da haben, glaube ich, libysche Dienste einfach aufgepasst.
Ich glaube, die haben sich das schon ziemlich genau angeschaut. Ich meine, immerhin links und rechts fallen die Diktatoren. Das konnte dem Gaddafi ja nicht ganz egal sein. Letztlich hat es ihm im wenig genützt, wie wir gemerkt haben. Aber zumindest wussten sie schon, wer ihr Feind ist.
Die waren ja auch sehr geschickt gewesen. Sie haben es jetzt nicht abgeschaltet. Sie haben es gedrosselt, die Durchsatzgeschwindigkeit.
Sie haben das Netz langsam gemacht.
Die war abends und am Wochenende langsam. Ja, das muss ich heimisch sagen, dass kein Netz da ist. Es ist ja da, es ist nur sehr langsam und macht keinen Spaß mehr zu benutzen. Ein YouTube-Video gucken war wohl eher nicht Spaß. Ja, das war aber nicht das Thema, weil das war ja trotzdem gesperrt.
Also Twitter war einfach generell gesperrt.
Wie Facebook auch gesperrt war. Aber auch immer nur zeitweise, also nicht durchgehend.
Sondern das ist immer so, wie kann man gerade nicht erreichen und es gibt da ein Problem, aber das niemand behaupten könnte, jetzt ist ja alles vorbei. Das heißt, diesen eigentlichen psychologischen Effekt, den sie in Ägypten dann ausgemacht haben, haben sie versucht, schon mal bewusst zu verhindern.
Genau. Also ich fand das sehr, sehr spannend auch, das zu beobachten. Es gibt ja Seiten im Netz, wo ich mir die Durchsatzstatistiken von denen anschauen kann. Und das war wirklich immer schön zu sehen, die Sinusquirven im Endeffekt. Und ja, da waren wir auch ziemlich machtlos. Was sollten wir da tun? Großartig. Wir haben halt unsere DNS-Server geöffnet und haben halt mitgeteilt, hey, hier ist Twitter-DNS-Server, also das müsst ihr eingeben, auf Twitter zu kommen. Das für Facebook, das für Google-Mail. Und das ging dann auch irgendwie. Aber auch nie so eine breite Kommunikation hat stattgefunden wie zu Ägypten, weil wir meist noch müde waren von der Ägyptensache. Das war einfach sehr anstrengend. Da haben wir mehrere Tage im Endeffekt durchgearbeitet und das war sehr, sehr, sehr anstrengend. Und für Libyen, das war direkt danach, hatte auch keiner wirklich die Energie und die Kraft gehabt. Die wir dann aber hatten, als es in Syrien angefangen hat. Syrien ist ja auch eine Diktatur, hätte es gedacht. Und dort haben wir auch Netzzensur festgeschrieben, Überwachung und haben dann dagegen Gegenmaßnahmen.
Was heißt, Sie haben das festgestellt? Wie stellt ihr das fest?
Indem z.B. syrische Bürger bei uns im IRC aufschlagen und sagen, hey, ich habe hier ein Zertifikat, das sieht komisch aus, könnt ihr mir dazu was sagen? Ein Facebook-Zertifikat. Dann schaut man sich das anschildfest.
Also ein Zertifikat für den HTTPS-Zugang zur Webseite. Genau. Das, was dann im Browser angezeigt wird.
Genau, und dann stellt man fest, dass das Zertifikat falsch ist. Mehr als ein Mittelattacken. Und das ist dann im Endeffekt die ersten Zeichen. Dann fängt man an, untersucht das und verschafft sich Zutritt zu syrischen Servern. Und fängt an, von da aus zu pingen und solche Dinge. Und sich mal den Traffic anzugucken. Plötzlich waren wir auf dem syrischen Backbone. Der Publikations-Backbone. Da standen offen wie Scheunentore die Blue-Code-Geräte.
Was für Geräte?
Blue-Code. Was ist das? Blue-Code ist eine Herstellerin aus den Staaten von eigentlich Firewalls für Firmen. Kann man aber auch sehr gut benutzen, um Netz-Traffic-Shaping zu machen, also das alles zu verdichten. Oder auch um Seiten zu sperren. Firmen kennt man vielleicht bei einigen, dass ich nicht jede Netzseite erreichen kann. Das macht man nicht mit einem Software-Filter, sondern schreibt man am besten eine Hardware hin, gerade bei großen Netzwerken, und gibt den ganzen Regeln mit. Dann haben wir uns Lockfiles davon mal runtergeladen. Die waren damals vier Monate alt, also mittlerweile fünf Monate alt.
Versteh ich dich richtig. Ihr könntet von außen direkt auf die finalen Firewalls des Landes zugreifen?
Fast direkt, ja.
Und die waren einfach schlecht geschützt?
Schlechte Admins, sehr schlechte Admins.
Also es war jetzt gar nicht mal so eine ausgeprägte kriminelle Energie vonnöten, um da irgendwelche Informationen zu bekommen?
Das war sehr einfach.
Und was konnte man dann sehen?
Wir konnten feststellen, was mit dem Internet-Traffic passiert. Also gut, klar, gesperrt, Pornografie, das ist in so einem Land fast normal. Glücksspielseiten, viele Werbeserver, das fand ich sehr angenehm, das fand ich sehr lustig. Online-Werbung war zum Beispiel auch blockiert. Verschlüsselte Facebook-Verbindung, verschlüsselte Google-Verbindung, verschlüsselte Twitter-Verbindung, also Sauschelnetworks, die Verschlüsselte-Verbindung gesperrt.
Damit die unverschlüsselten benutzt werden dürfen?
Müssen. Müssen. Und das dann aber auch mitgeschnitten. Ja.
Und das war auch sichtbar?
Das kann man ablesen in den Regeln. Also es wird immer Alarm gegeben an einen Operator, den man Facebook aufruft. Und dann kann der, also dass es, wie es im Regelfall abläuft, an seinem Operator-Terminal den speziellen mitschneiden. Aber auch halt natürlich, da es ja nicht sicher ist, Passwörter wegfischen. Das machen sie ja auch in Bahrain zum Beispiel. In Bahrain werden Passwörter weggefischt und Profile. Und dann wird versucht, über das Profil eines Oppositionellen den Rest der Gruppe zu unterwandern.
Und wie lange hat das gedauert, bis ihr da diese Analyse abgeschlossen habt in Syrien? Und wie lange ist das jetzt her?
Das ist jetzt ungefähr drei, vier Wochen her, bis wir die veröffentlicht haben. Wir hatten sie schon zwei Wochen länger. Und ich meine, das sind gepackt 54 Gigabyte, unpackt 300 Gigabyte. Das haben wir natürlich nicht so eine alleine. Das haben wir crowdsourced so ein bisschen. Und haben in all diesen Logfiles das Gleiche festgestellt. Die Blue-Code-Handbücher sind offen im Netz einsehbar. Sie gibt es auf der Blue-Code-Seite zum Downloaden. Da gibt es auch eine schöne Support-Form. Wenn man eine Regel nicht versteht, kann man da mal nachfragen. Ja, und da haben wir dann diese Informationen halt herbekommen und konnten dadurch die Log-Files analysieren. Und ja, haben dann aber auch die Sicherheitsmaßnahmen ergreifen können natürlich. Wir sind durchaus in der Lage, Daten, also Videos, Bilder, Texte aus Syrien rauszuschmuggeln, ohne dass es in deinem Blue-Code-Gerät aufhält.
Und wie kriegt man diese Informationen nach Syrien wiederum?
IRC-Traffic wird nicht mitgeschnitten.
Sicher? Ja, weil ihr es ja gesehen habt.
Wir haben es ja gesehen. Aber auch...
Da frage ich mich natürlich, warum?
Aber ich glaube, es ist keiner mehr auf dem Schirm. Wie alt ist diese Technologie? 20 Jahre?
Gute Frage.
Ungefähr.
It's here forever.
Ja, genau. Wer denkt denn noch, wir benutzen noch IRC aus den Nerds?
Keine Ahnung. Also ich habe so den Eindruck, dass eine ganze Menge Leute das eigentlich benutzen.
Ja, ja, in unserer Welt vielleicht, aber da draußen doch nicht. Das ist doch das Spannende. Also wenn ich irgendwie in meinen Nicht-Nerd-Freundeskreis gehe, kennt keiner IRC. Die sind froh, dass sie ICQ benutzen können.
1988.
Das ist über 20 Jahre alt. Da ist doch keiner mehr auf dem Schirm.
23.
Ich kann nicht gut rechnen, ich bin Benk, Entschuldigung.
Okay, gut, also interessant. Ich meine, man hat schon häufig gedacht, dass Technologien nicht auf dem Radar von irgendjemand sind, so lange bis sie dann eben auf einmal auf dem Radar von irgendjemand sind. Ich meine, das kann sich schon von heute auf morgen ändern.
Natürlich. Was wir aber auch machen, ist SSL-Verbindung und wir erklären den Leuten, wie sie Zertifikate vergleichen, dass es passt. Wir erklären ihnen, wie sie das machen müssen. Also, das ist ja immer, wir erzählen immer den Leuten, vergleiche Zertifikate, aber wir sagen ihnen nicht, wie es geht. Also, wenn ich mir so die Zeitung angucke, so eine CT, unbedingt Zertifikate abgleichen. Ja, aber es steht halt nicht da, wie es geht und das würde mein Dad deswegen niemals können.
Das ist schon eine relativ komplexe Materie, das verstehen eigentlich auch so die advancederen Leute.
Ja gut, aber ich kann Leuten erklären, wie sie Buchstaben vergleichen müssen, vom Fingerprint und vom Open Key. Das kann ich ihnen erklären, das ist nicht schwer. Die müssen auch gar nicht wissen, warum das, was da passiert, die müssen nur verstehen, was sie vergleichen müssen. Also das ist ja so ein Problem von den Nerds, dass sie auf den Anspruch haben, dass jeder das immer auch verstehen muss, was da passiert. Ich bin auf dem Punkt, er muss es erstmal bedienen können, bevor er es verstehen muss.
Wie groß schätzt du denn so die eingefleischte und wirklich techniknetzaffine Gruppe von Leuten da in Syrien ein, in anderen Ländern? Ich meine, man hat ja immer so diese Vorstellung, dass das so ein bisschen die dritte Welt ist. Das ist definitiv nicht wahr.
Also einer meiner Kontakte ist Maschinenbaustudent. Es gibt viele junge Leute, die sich sehr interessieren für Technologie und für Netztechnologie. Aber ich glaube, so richtig die krasse Nerdcode, wie wir das hier haben in Europa, gibt es überhaupt nicht. Also da gibt es vielleicht eine Handvoll oder zwei. Das liegt aber glaube ich auch daran, dass einfach der Zununftstechnologie bei uns hier völlig anders ist. Er ist hier bei uns viel freier. Also auch von, es ist kein Teufelszeug mehr. Und ich glaube durchaus, dass von denen, die jetzt mit Telecomix gearbeitet haben, ein paar sich werter mit Technologie beschäftigen werden, weil sie es spannend finden, weil sie sich was damit machen kann. Das ist ja eigentlich auch gut so.
Das heißt, abgesehen jetzt von konkreten Freiheitsdienstleistungen betätigt ihr euch mindestens auch indirekt so als Inkubator für eine vielleicht etwas informierteren Teil der Gesellschaft, der künftig dann vielleicht die technischen Maßnahmen auch schon ohne externe Hilfe einleiten kann.
Das auch. Wir versuchen, durch unser Wissen weiterzugeben, so viel wie geht, an so viele wie geht, weil dann müssen wir es irgendwann nicht mehr machen. Wir versuchen auch für uns rauszuarbeiten, warum wir bestimmte Technologien verwenden wollen. Also ich kann natürlich meinem Dad sagen, benutzt PGP. Er wird aber nicht verstehen, warum er es tun soll. Man muss das warum verstehen. Und als er das verstanden hat, wird er es auch benutzen wollen. Und wenn ich mit meinem Dad drüber rede, der ist 67, ist nicht so leicht, weil er einfach andere Sicht auf das Gerät hat. Wenn ich das meinem Cousin von 17 erzähle, der ist ja voll dafür.
Der nickt nur noch.
Der nickt nur noch, das mache ich doch schon längst. Das sind halt auch Sachen, mit denen wir uns beschäftigen. Also warum möchte ich eine verschlüsselte Netzverbindung haben? Warum möchte ich verschlüsselte E-Mails haben? Und warum möchte ich auch in einem Social-Network nicht alle meine Daten preisgeben? Auch das versuchen wir den Leuten zu erklären.
Jetzt habt ihr ja da sehr viel Aktivismus entfaltet. Das ist ja sicherlich auch ein sehr, wie soll ich sagen, sehr erfüllendes Element. Dieses Gefühl zu helfen, dieses Gefühl auch Dinge ranzubringen. Auf der anderen Seite viele durchgearbeitete Nächte. Da macht sich ja dann auch schnell mal Erschöpfung breit. Bei dir hat sich die Erschöpfung auch breit gemacht. Bis hin zu so einem, ja ich weiß nicht, wie du es selber nennen würdest, aber so ein Extrem-Burnout-Gefühl, wo oben und unten nicht mehr so klar lokalisierbar waren.
Ja, das war ein Burnout gepackt mit einer tiefen Depression zusammen. Was aber auch aufgrund dieser Situation entstanden ist.
Aber warum ist das so deprimierend?
Weil wir nicht nur das Positive sehen, was immer wieder passiert, sondern auch viel, viel schlimme Dinge. Wir haben Videos online gestellt, wo Menschen erschossen werden. Die haben wir halt gesehen zuerst, diese Videos. Wir haben Postings online gestellt für Leute, die in Gefängnissen waren, wo sie über ihre Folter berichten. Wir haben Berichte aus dem Land geschmuggelt, für Zeitungen zum Beispiel, wo einer berichtet hat, dass das Assad-Regime nimmt einen Sohn einer Familie gefangen und erpresst ein Lösegeld in einer sehr hohen Summe, das die Familie niemals bezahlen kann. Die leihen sich also Geld zusammen, um ihren Sohn wiederzubekommen. Und die werden es nie zurückzahlen können. Danach ist das Regime, aber auch alle wissen, warum das passiert ist und dass der Junge daran schuld ist, dass diese Familie in Armut leben muss. Und das ist einfach ein ganz krasser Psychotherapeut, der da passiert, indem wir uns selbst aussetzen, indem wir uns diese Sache erstmal ansehen. Also ich will wissen, was ich hochlade. Ich werde nicht blind ein Video hochladen. Ich werde auch nicht blind einen Blogpost veröffentlichen. Ich will erstmal wissen, was tue ich da eigentlich, für wen tue ich das.
Das heißt, in gewisser Hinsicht hat ihr auch so journalistische Tätigkeit übernommen. Kann man das so sagen?
Wir überprüfen nicht die Wahrheit, TM. Sondern wir schauen nur, in welchem Kontext steht dieses Bild, dieses Video, dieser Text, um das für uns einzuordnen. Das ist ganz wichtig, ich will einen Kontext haben.
Also so eine Art Quellen-Plausibilität.
Genau, eine ganz grobe Quellen-Plausibilität. Das ist ein schönes Wort.
Ja, ja, das ist ja logisch, man weiß nicht, was die Wahrheit ist. Man hat ja auch das ganze Jahr immer diese schönen Filme in der Tagesschau, Quelle, Internet. Der Wahrheitsgehalt konnte von uns nicht überprüft werden. Da fragt man sich mal, ob das bei den anderen Informationen eigentlich dann immer der Fall ist. Auf einmal so beim Internet. Es war ja auch so eine interessante Kapitulation der Medienordnung eigentlich zu betrachten. Ich will das jetzt gar nicht überdramatisieren, aber es war gerade in dieser Situation des Arabischen Frühlings so einerseits großes Medieninteresse, andererseits kaum eine Möglichkeit, in irgendeiner Form vor Ort zu sein. Also in Ägypten war es einfacher, als es dann später in Libyen war und Syrien ist ja derzeit der Ausnahmezustand, eigentlich was das von dort Berichten betrifft. Und jetzt sehen auch alle, und ich denke, das ist auch jetzt wirklich dem letzten klassischen Medienvertreter klar geworden, es ist eigentlich fast nur noch das Internet, wo überhaupt irgendetwas durchsägt.
Ja, und was mich geärgert hat, war, dass irgendwie plötzlich alle auf ADNZDF einschlugen während der Ägyptensache, weil Al-Jazeera so viel berichten würde. Wenn man sich das mal angeschaut hat, das waren die gleichen sechs Filme in Dauerschleife. Da war nicht viel Neues dabei. Weil wenn man so ein paar Stunden Al-Jazeera geguckt hat, das war die gleiche Dauerschleife. Die waren nicht viel besser.
Ja, und ich meine, wenn sie besser waren, dann ist es halt auch einfach klar, dass das einfach mal ihr Kulturkreis ist. Der Kernkulturkreis hätten jetzt, sagen wir mal, denselben Aufstand in Weißrussland. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob unbedingt Al-Jazeera da da vorwärts.
Al-Jazeera ist gerade in New York bei der Räumung dabei. Von Occupy Leuten. Und macht Live-Übertragung.
Mittlerweile haben die sicherlich auch einen neuen Markenkern für sich entdeckt. Neu ist er in gewisser Hinsicht auch nicht. Al-Jazeera hatte ja auch schon eine längere Geschichte mit dem Irak, aber das war ja dann eben auch immer der arabische Kontext. Mittlerweile entwickeln sie sich da zu so einer globalen journalistischen Macht. Das ist nochmal eine ganz interessante Geschichte. Aber ich denke auch, AD und ZDF dann immer vorzuwerfen, dass sie jetzt gerade nicht 5 Minuten schneller waren als alle anderen, dasselbe Video zu zeigen. Das geht dann auch so ein bisschen am Thema vorbei. Nichtsdestotrotz zeigt sich, dass das hat ja auch Wikileaks in diesem und letzten Jahr gezeigt, dass auf einmal eine ganz andere Quellenkultur sich entwickelt. Auch eine Quellenunkultur.
Auch eine Unkultur, ja.
Und dass dieses generelle diffuse ja, im Internet können Informationen auch falsch sein. Ja, können Sie, was so eine einfache Erkenntnis ist, was man also bisher immer dadurch ignoriert hat, indem man einfach das ganze Internet einfach ignoriert hat, jetzt sich einfach gezwungen sieht, diese Ignoranz einfach aufzuheben. Dass man einfach sagen muss, ok, alles klar, das war jetzt hier eine Internetquelle, aber die muss eigentlich genauso hinterfragt werden, wie jede andere auch. Bisher konnte man sich mal darauf verlassen, dass wenn das von unserem Korrespondenten kommt, dann kommt das von irgendjemanden, den dieser Korrespondent schon lange kennt. Also es waren immer so tradierte Kanäle, die über Jahre gewachsen sind und deswegen konnte man eben etwas trauen, nur weil es eben durch diese Tür gegangen ist. Und jetzt hat man einfach dieses große Scheunentor IP-Netzwerke und es kann einfach alles jederzeit von überall kommen und das erfordert natürlich auch eine ganz andere Art und Weise, darüber nachzudenken.
Ja, das haben wir bei Telecomix ja auch getan und wir haben für uns festgestellt, wir werden nicht den Wahrheitsgehalt einer Quelle angeben können. Wir werden nicht sagen können, das ist wahr oder das ist gelogen. Für uns ist aber auch, wir sind auf dem Punkt, dass diese Bewertung muss jeder für sich selbst machen. Also jeder Konsument von Videos und Bildern und Texten muss für sich selbst entscheiden, will ich das glauben oder nicht. Es gibt eine Seite von der Bahrain Cyber Army, ja die gibt es wirklich, die Propaganda gegen im Ausland lebende Menschenrechtsaktivisten betreibt. Also zum Beispiel die Gründerin des Human Rights Office of Bahrain wird darauf regelmäßig niedergeschrieben. Und das ist aber für viele war rein eine seriöse Quelle. Jetzt gibt es eine neue Seite, die sich auch mit Revolutionsdingen beschäftigt und eine Koalition von Jugendorganisationen bildet. Sie hat damit zu tun. Und ich las dann diesen Artikel dazu auf dieser Seite und stellte fest, dass einfach alles darauf gelogen ist. Hätte ich nicht gewusst, was da wirklich passiert ist, im Bezug auf diese Seite, weil wir hosten die, dann hätte man nicht wissen können, ist das wahr, ist das falsch. Also ich weiß nur aufgrund meiner anderen Erfahrungen, dass das, was sie dort schreiben, falsch ist. Und Propaganda.
Und in dem Fall war es wirklich alles falsch.
Alles. Also angefangen von wer die Seite gebaut bis wo wird sie gehostet, war einfach alles falsch.
Ja, aber es bleibt natürlich auch immer irgendwas hängen.
Genau, und jetzt ist natürlich auch die Sache, ich weiß das.
Wer bist du schon?
Und viele andere, die das lesen, wissen das nicht. Das ist Falsches. So, wer hat jetzt Recht? Wo liegt jetzt die Wahrheit? Also das ist, in meinem Universum habe ich Recht und sie sagen die Unwahrheit. Jemand anderes wird genau das Gegenteil für sich feststellen. Und wir sind halt immer gern bereit, die Wahrheiten zu glauben, die in unser eigenes Weltbild reinpassen, die in unseren eigenen Lebenskontext reinpassen. Also wir zerreißen ja auch gerne Sachen aus Kontexten raus, wenn wir sie weitergeben. Also das kennen wir ja mit Zitaten, die verkürzt werden und dergleichen. Und ohne das, wo es passiert ist. Und sind bereit, eine uns genehme Wahrheit anzunehmen. Also Al-Jazeera war jeder bereit, sofort die Bilder als wahr anzunehmen. Ob das wahr ist oder nicht, wissen wir nicht. Wir gehen davon aus. Und ja, das ist halt ein ganz spannender Prozess gerade. Also der da draußen Passierte. Was nehmen wir als Wahrheit an und was nicht?
Das Problem ist an sich nichts Neues.
Es geht nicht so.
Nur, dass es jetzt eben so eine vollkommen geänderte Quellenkultur gibt.
Genau. Und das macht es halt noch viel krasser eigentlich. Und auch Telecomix ist Teil dieser Quellenkultur. Und vom Ansehen bis zum Veröffentlichen dieser Quellen vergeht halt bei uns irgendwie eine Stunde. Und wir hauen das halt raus, das Zeug.
Was jetzt, vorhin dabei eigentlich zu schildern, was diese Nachrichten jetzt so mit euch angestellt haben?
Ja, es hat halt irgendwie, einige Aktivisten hatten dann irgendwie wirklich ein Nervous Breakdowns, also richtig krasse Nervenzusammenbrüche deswegen, weil sehr eindringlich geschildert ist oft, oder auch die Bilder sehr brutal sind. Und wenn man ein bisschen, also wenn man nicht so hart ist, dann ist es schwer, das auf Dauer auszuhalten. Ich selbst hab davon eine starke Depression gekriegt. Und das Schlimmste eigentlich ist, man spricht nicht drüber. Wir hatten kein Debriefing in der Gruppe, kein externes Debriefing, und man spricht nicht drüber. Depressionen, das haben die anderen nicht. Ich hab nur selbst da ist, nicht drüber sprechen, weiter machen.
Weil die Probleme haben ja eigentlich die anderen, und man will ja nur helfen.
Und für mich wurde dieser Knoten auf dem Camp gelöst. Also da war das TCC Camp unglaublich wertvoll für mich.
Also wir reden vom Chaos-Communication-Camp in diesem Jahr, im August in Vienowfurt, das vierte. Da war Telecomix dann auch selber präsent.
Wurde im Village, genau. Und ich hab da zum ersten Mal die Jungs getroffen.
Ah, ihr kanntest schon alle noch gar nicht so live. Niemanden.
Ja, ich kannte Bilder von ihnen. Aber es hätte noch jemand auf dem Bild sein können. Und wir haben genau über dieses Problem dann auf dem Camp viel gesprochen. Und wir hatten dann den Plan, Telecomix zuzumachen, um uns selbst davon zu befreien.
Den hattet ihr schon vorher.
Den hatten wir auf dem Camp endgültig gehabt. Also ich hatte ja einen Vortrag auf dem Camp. Und wir haben uns dann eigentlich auf das, dass wir diesen Slot benutzen, um Telecomix runterzufahren, live auf der Bühne. Das haben wir auch getan. Während ein Video lief, in dem ein Bot von uns, Cameron, das ist einer unserer Bots, befohlen hat, das System abzuschalten, haben die Chrome-Jobs-Server ausgemacht.
Also die Server mit den Modem-Einwahlen, die Server, die...
Die IRC-Server, Web-Server, alles weg. Wir haben es zugemacht.
Und dann?
Haben wir uns echt...
Das ist alles lustig, erstmal. Wir wussten gar nicht, was passiert.
Wir haben uns echt frei gefühlt. Wir haben uns richtig frei gefühlt. Das war großartig. Und dann, 10 Minuten später... Was fällt euch ein, einfach Telecomix zuzumachen? Wir brauchen das doch.
Sagte wer? Menschen, Besucher.
Und so, ach, ihr braucht das. Wer soll denn den Arabern helfen? Du zum Beispiel. Also es war dann sehr spannend, auch diese Forderungshaltung gegenüber Telecomix. Ihr habt das schon mal gemacht, ihr könnt das doch immer noch machen.
Das gab es doch schon immer.
Ja, das habt ihr doch schon immer so gemacht. Ja, wir haben keine Lust mehr. Wir hatten einst aber weiterlaufen gehabt vom IRC, um den Syrern, denen wir schon gearbeitet haben, nicht das zu nehmen, weil das wäre gemeingewesen. Das macht man nicht. Und während dieser Pause haben wir die Lokfals gefunden. Die syrischen. Während wir zu waren eigentlich.
Welche Lokfals jetzt?
Die aus den syrischen Blukord-Routern. Da hatten wir eigentlich gerade zu gehabt.
Die habt ihr wo gefunden? Im Netz?
Ja im Netz.
Ok, also ihr habt eure Sachen untergefahren und gesagt, ok endlich frei. Dann habt ihr als nächstes dann aber doch gleich schon wieder weiter gemacht.
Ja, da kann ich nicht aufhören damit. Du hast den Druck raus. Du hast den Druck unglaublich raus. Und halt auf dem Camp haben wir viel mit anderen Hackern gesprochen. Plötzlich war so das Thema Depressionen ist bei vielen Hackern und Aktivisten kein neues Thema. Man spricht nur nicht drüber. Man spricht nicht drüber.
Aber man ist ja ein harter Kerl.
Genau. Man ist ja ein harter Kerl oder eine harte Hexe, was auch immer. Das Problem hat man nur selbst. Andere haben das nicht. Ich bin schwach. Ich darf ja nicht drüber sprechen. Falsch. Muss ich ganz klar sagen, das ist falsch. Wir müssen darüber sprechen. Es gibt so eine Seite bluehackers.org, wo es darum geht, was kann ich für mich selbst tun, wenn es mir nicht gut geht. So Essenszyklus, Schlafzyklus, solche Sachen. Also einfach mal so achte auf deinen Schlafzyklus. Achte auf, dass du regelmäßig isst. Oder für denjenigen, der einen Betroffenen kennt, achte darauf, dass er regelmäßig isst, dass er regelmäßig schläft. Solche Dinge. So Basics einfach. Kann natürlich niemals eine ärztliche Behandlung ersetzen. Aber es kann einen schon mal helfen, ein bisschen die Normalität zurückzufinden. Und das mache ich seitdem auch. Ich schlafe regelmäßiger, esse drei Mahlzeiten am Tag plus Zwischenmahlzeiten. Und das ist durchaus eine Sache, wo es mir besser geht. Ich gehe spätestens um eins ins Bett. Und stehe spätestens aber auch um neun Uhr auf. Einfach um ein Zyklus, um eine Struktur im Leben zu haben.
Um einfach auch, es gibt einem auch Festigkeit.
Genau. Man ist halt auch einfach mal nicht da. Man ist halt auch einfach mal nicht erreichbar.
So. Und das heißt, ihr wart also dann, habt irgendwie zehn Minuten lang Telecomix runtergefahren, oder vielleicht auch mal einen halben Tag laufen lassen, dann wart ihr aber schon wieder am Hacken, oder was?
Ja, wir haben es dann, es kamen plötzlich unglaublich viele Leute, die helfen wollten. Und einige kannten wir. Da haben wir gesagt, hier, da, der ISI selber läuft noch, sprich mit den Leuten. Das ist okay. Wir haben jetzt Pause. Wir machen jetzt mal Urlaub, wir campen gerade. Ja, wir campen gerade. Die Webseite war dann irgendwie ein großes Re-Begarrom, das heißt auf Englisch, also Re-Rebuild, oder Wir bauen neu. Der geilste Tweet darauf war Telecomix Pulse Pirat Piran, weil nämlich die so was Ähnliches auf ihre Seite geschrieben haben, die sie nie wieder aufgemacht haben. Wir hatten also wie gesagt groß und schwedisch wie Begarrom drunter das Video, das ich vorher auf dem Camp gezeigt hatte. Und das war's. Und das war mehrere Wochen so, die Seite. Wir haben nicht mehr getittert, wir haben ISV Server waren zu, der Hauptraum war dann gemutet irgendwann, also als dann halt ein paar ISV Server wieder hochgefahren, da war aber der Hauptraum gemutet, der konnte nicht drinnen sprechen. Wir haben einen Idle-Kontest erst mal gemacht. Also wer fliegt zuerst aufgrund erbrechender Verbindung. Wir hatten da sehr viel Spaß. Wir haben in unserem Network-Operation-Channel wieder irgendwie Katzenbilder ausgetauscht, wie früher.
Also es war im einigen Sinne so ein Reset.
Und der hat uns gut getan.
Dann?
Irgendwann dann...
Dann habt ihr quasi schon auf euren eigenen Rechnern diese Logfiles aus Syrien gehabt und ihr wusstet irgendwie...
Dann müssen wir was machen.
The big shit continues und wir sitzen jetzt hier und bauen uns eine Nase.
Genau, geht nicht. Ein paar Leute haben ja mit Syrien gearbeitet. Dadurch haben wir jetzt auch neue Leute im Team plötzlich, die super großartig sind. Und wir haben dann neue Webseite gebaut, hochgefahren. Tada, da sind wir wieder. Und dann haben wir das halt gemacht. Also wir haben dann ein paar Wochen noch die Logs gehabt und dann haben wir sie veröffentlicht. Und wir haben wieder angefangen zu twittern, haben wieder angefangen, ja, das zu tun, was wir vorher taten. Aber nebenher auch immer wieder diesen Politikaspekt. So, warum tun wir das? Was passiert da eigentlich? Also jetzt nicht rein technisch, sondern was passiert da politisch, wenn wir das tun? Also momentan, wir haben in Syrien, haben wir das beste Beispiel einer Vorratsartensprechung von Access Blocking, wie missbrauchbar das ist. Und wir brauchen keinen, und zwar mit handelsüblicher Hardware. Also das ist jetzt nicht eine Spezialanfertigung oder ein neues Produkt, das kann man kaufen als Staat. Und wir kriegen das auch in Deutschland, wenn wir das haben wollen. Also wir haben das beste Beispiel, was eine Vorratsartensprechung oder auch ein Access Blocking anrichten kann. Dass nämlich so undurchsichtig die Regellisten der Administrator einfach einstellen kann. Da kann mir noch jemand erzählen, das BKA kontroleriert die Listen. Wenn ich als Administrator möchte, kann ich da viel mehr reinschreiben. Es kriegt keiner mit. Und wir haben da das beste Beispiel, warum das, was unsere Politiker in Europa fordern, totaler Bullshit ist. Und dann hat eine Frau Merkel am Rand der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz gestanden und meinte, dass Twitter und Facebook nicht mehr zensiert werden können, weder in Tunesien, Ägypten, China, noch anderswo. Das ist ein Stück weit auch unser Verdienst.
Unser im Sinne von?
Deutschlands.
Deutschland.
Deutschland. Deutschland und Herr Westerwelle haben ja auch der Gaddafi gestürzt. Und dann wird man halt auch zynisch. Wir haben diese Logfiles veröffentlicht, wir haben gezeigt, was funktioniert. Und der Guardian hat drüber geschrieben, die New York Times hat drüber geschrieben. Und dann hat auch irgendwann endlich der Spiegel drüber geschrieben. Aber ansonsten ist es untergegangen. Den wenigsten Medien ist klar gewesen, was sie da eigentlich getan haben mit der Veröffentlichung. Also nicht nur Beweis, dass westliche Firmen an Sicherheitstechnologie, die in die arabischen Länder gehen, wo Leute unterdrückt werden, die deswegen sterben müssen teilweise, damit einen guten Reibach machen, sondern auch, dass diese Technologie die ist, die eigentlich unsere Politiker seit Jahren haben wollen. Und dann genau, im schlimmsten Fall, kann man dann genau diese Dinge daraus machen. Und das ist irgendwie das, was glaube ich den Leuten gar nicht klar ist.
Das ist wahrscheinlich einfach auch schwer zu vermitteln auf der einen Seite. Auf der anderen Seite, denke ich, gehört natürlich auch ein extrem kluger Umgang mit den Medien dazu. Einfach nur irgendwas auf den Tisch zu legen und dann darauf zu warten, dass es aufgegriffen wird. Da hat sich jetzt auch das Wikileaks-Projekt und andere Leaks-Projekte schon immer schwer getan, weil es ist nicht einfach nur das. Sondern es ist einfach auch die Frage, wie man es begleitet und wie man es, ja, was man auch schon für eine Inszenierung darum macht.
Wir haben natürlich dann mit den Journalisten, die wir kannten, aufgrund der ägypten Nummer, gesprochen. Und das mitteilt hier, wir haben hier diese Daten. Und wenn du dann Fragen hast, frag mich. Ich bin für dich, ich bin für deine Fragen zu diesem Thema da. Also wirklich Betreuung von Journalisten, das ist wichtig. Bei uns machen das ja auch nur ein paar weniger, damit der Rest in Ruhe arbeiten kann. Was ich sehr gut finde, dieses Konzept, so lasst den Rest arbeiten. Und vor allem auch anonym arbeiten, wenn sie das möchten. Also es gibt Leute, die haben da Angst vor ihrer Courage, und das ist vollkommen in Ordnung.
Aber die können was, und die können auch was bewirken.
Genau.
Und dann hält man sie einfach da aus dem Strom raus.
Und wer jetzt nicht so viele Probleme hat, seinen Namen in der Zeitung wiederzufinden, der geht auf vielleicht andere Wege.
Genau.
Weil das wahrscheinlich trotzdem ein merkwürdiges Feeling ist, ne?
Es ist immer wieder bizarr irgendwie, sich selbst im Radio zu hören oder in einem Podcast oder seine Zitate in einem Zeitungspartikel zu lesen, ja.
Wie gut, dass du so wenig Zeit hast, gerade Podcasts zu hören. Bleibt dir das ja weitgehend erspart. It's crazy times we are in. Dieses Jahr und auch letztes Jahr schon, und es geht ja eigentlich auch schon seit einer Weile, aber man hat das Gefühl, gerade dieses Jahr hat es sich einfach ungemein verdichtet. Der Aktivismus aus dem Netz ist auf einmal auch ein großes Thema, was ja auch viel Welle gemacht hat und auch immer noch macht, ist so dieses Phänomen Anonymous, dessen Herkunft schon sehr schwer zu benennen ist und der auch so als Organisationskörper sehr schwer zu benennen ist. Das sagt ja eigentlich auch der Name auch schon aus. Was denkst du darüber?
Wir haben eine Hassliebe zu Anonymous, wie bei Telecomix. Also ich fand es sehr lustig, als ich in der deutschen Wikipedia las, dass Telecomix ein Subcluster von Anonymous sei. Und ich habe mir so, nein, ich habe es rausgelöscht, weil es falsch ist. Nächsten Tag kommt es wieder drin. Ja, ich habe es irgendwann aufgegeben.
Vandalismus.
Ja, wir haben da einigen Sachen zum Arabischen Frühling mit Anonymous zusammengearbeitet, weil die können sehr gut Faxe verschicken. Da sind die gut drin.
Weil es viele sind.
Weil es viele sind. Und die können das halt. Das sind Operation White Facts, wie die immer alle heißen weiterhin. Da sind die auch schon gewöhnt, Faxe zu verschicken.
Ja, wenn auch ohne Inhalt.
Wenn auch ohne Inhalt, ja. Und es zeigt halt ganz deutlich, dass Menschen was tun wollen. Also in meinen Augen sind das die ganzen Anonymous-Leute, die irgendwie Denial-of-Service-Attacken fahren, die irgendwie ihre Empörung Luft machen. Ganz konkret, weil konkret ein libysches Innenministerium Denial-of-Service ist, oder was auch immer. Das sind oft gute Menschen. Also ganz klassisch gute Menschen, die wollen was bewirken, die wissen nur nicht, was sie tun sollen.
Die sind eigentlich unorganisiert. Die wissen, sie wollen irgendwie dabei sein, oder sie würden gerne was bewirken und wollen helfen. Aber sie stecken jetzt nicht in solchen definierten Strukturen, wie es Telecomix ist, oder Chaos-Compto-Tactob und andere Gruppen, die sich schon lange gefunden haben, die irgendwie einen Plan haben, und die da auch ziemlich genau wissen, in welche Richtung das geht. Es sind auch viele junge Leute dabei, oder?
Ja, so was ich mitbekomme, sind sehr viele junge Leute dabei. Das finde ich auch sehr spannend. Ich finde das auch gut. Mein Problem ist nur ihre Destruktivität. Also bei Telecomix versuchen wir immer, etwas aufzubauen.
Infrastruktur.
Infrastruktur schaffen oder halt positive Dinge zu tun für das Netz. Wenn Anonymous negative Dinge tut.
Blockaden, DDoS, Unterfahren.
Ja, es gab schon Augenblick, da wurde eine Seite der Observes von Anonymous und wir haben sie gemirrored. Ich müsste mal nachschauen, das hatten wir denn für zwei Tage gemirrored gehabt diese Seite.
Weil sie unter Attacke ist von Anonymous.
Weil sie nicht mehr erreichbar war. Also ich wusste nicht, was ist Anonymous, was haben wir jetzt später erfahren. Es gab einen Telecomixer, der No Pants, der sagte immer, Anonymous ist Ying zu Telecomix Young. Und das ist auch irgendwie richtig.
Also gehört sozusagen eigentlich zum gleichen Kulturkreis, aber es ist die andere Hälfte.
Es ist der gleiche Kulturkreis, es ist eine andere Hälfte. Wir versuchen es konstruktiv zu machen. Anonymous ist mir zu destruktiv, obwohl da viele mittlerweile zu uns überlaufen, was ich sehr gut finde. Die dann aber erst mal die neuen Spielregeln kennenlernen müssen.
Was man hier nicht einfach drauf losfeuert.
Nicht einfach drauf losfeuern. Wir werden niemals zu einer Revolution aufrufen. Wir machen keine Revolution, wir unterstützen Infrastruktur. Aber Telecomix wird nie zu einer Revolution aufrufen.
Also Anonymous ist natürlich in der Hinsicht auch wirklich extrem aufgeblasen. Man merkt auch, dass da irgendwie so eine Hilflosigkeit kompensiert werden muss. Ich denke, das ist auch eigentlich das, was diese Gruppe so treibt. Und wenn man jetzt mal auch so die Hintergründe anschaut, also man kann jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht alles darauf allein zurückführen. Aber man weiß ja, kulturell ist das Ganze ja, zumindest der Name, geboren in diesem sagenumwobenen Forchan-Universum, wo diese Kultur, dass ich bin, ich bin nur einer von vielen, ich bin nicht sichtbar, ich trage quasi eine Maske, die sich ja dann eben konkret dann auch eine Realität in dieser Guy Fawkes Maske da ausgedrückt hat und irgendwie, ich weiß zwar nicht, was ich jetzt hier tue, aber das Internet ist mein Kulturraum und da fühle ich mich zu Hause. Und dann kamen halt so die Leute, die wollen mir da was wegnehmen und die wollen jetzt irgendwelche Regeln setzen, die mir nicht passen. Das hat sich ja dann ganz konkret in dieser absurden Tom Cruise Video-Geschichte Scientology et cetera.
Das ist ja nochmal der ganze Scientology-Kram. Das können die ja richtig gut. Also auch wirklich Hintergründe verständlich machen bei Scientology und dergleichen. Das können Anonymous richtig gut. Ich fand auch die Anonymous-Proteste vor den Scientology-Kirchen, das fand ich gigantisch. Aber es schafft so eine...
Das war dann halt auch so der Urknall. Ich denke, wenn das so nicht stattgefunden hätte, dann hätte es jetzt auch nie so die Bedeutung bekommen. Nur jetzt ist es einfach so populär, sich dem anzuschließen.
Und so beliebig.
Ja, genau. Und dann eben auch beliebig, weil jeder will dann jetzt irgendwie davon teil sein. Und man hat so diesen Gedanken, man ist jetzt einfach ein Partikel in so einem Cyber-Sandstorm, der quasi alles dahin fegt, was einem gerade ein bisschen in den Kram passt. Das ist ja auch so eine Machtfantasie schon wieder fast. Klar, das ist jetzt eben der kritische Punkt. Trotz alledem ist es klar, woher es sich entwickelt hat. Es ist schon eben auch so eine ähnliche Antwort, wie ihr sie ja eigentlich auch versucht habt zu geben, so auf dieses In-Frage-Stellen der eigenen Werte. Von Kommunikationsfreiheit und Verbreitung von Wahrheit in Anführung.
Und auch das In-Frage-Stellen von Machtstrukturen natürlich. Genau. Das ist mir auch erst vor ein paar Wochen gekommen, dass eigentlich die ganze Zeit Machtstrukturen in Frage stellen mit Telecomix. Und das finde ich auch sehr, sehr spannend. Es tut ja Anonymous auch Machtstrukturen in Frage stellen. Da halt an konkreteren Dingen wie Mastercard, Visa Card, Weibiggelegs damals oder Paypal sagen, dass diese Macht, diese Unternehmen auf den Geldfluss, das ist nicht okay. Und das haben sie ja auch damit in Frage gestellt einfach. Und ich glaube, wenn generell die ganzen Netzprotestbewegungen, davon gibt es ja also die ganzen Anonymous-Bewegungen, die verschiedenen oder auch andere Protestbewegungen, wenn wir alle ein bisschen weg von dem konkreten Problem auf eine Metaebene gehen und mal überlegen, was tun wir da eigentlich? Oder was wollen wir tun? Und was hat das für Implikationen nicht nur bei mir lokal, sondern wirklich global? Dass wir da zu ganz, ganz spannenden Ergebnissen kommen und auch wahrscheinlich zu Sachen, wo wir im Netz fast alle unterschreiben würden. Dass wir halt eben diese Machtstrukturen im Netz in Frage stellen, dass halt ein Geldstrom wie ein Datenstrom funktioniert im Endeffekt und dass nicht eine Instanz das aufhalten darf. Also RFC für Geldströme finde ich total geil. Und es wird aber glaube ich noch ein Prozess von 1, 2, 3 Jahren sein, dass wir allesamt soweit sind, die in solchen Gruppen organisiert sind oder nicht organisiert sind, festzustellen, was wollen wir eigentlich? Wir wissen nur, was wir nicht wollen, weil wir wissen nicht, was wir wollen. Wir sagen, wir wollen ein freies Netz. Was ist denn ein freies Netz? Das hat mir bis heute keiner gesagt, was es ist. Und ich weiß es selbst auch noch nicht genau. Und die Diskussion fände ich auch viel spannender als in diversen Arbeitskreisen, wo ich war, wo dann wegen 1,30 Mails geschrieben werden auf einer Mailingliste.
Man hat fast so den Eindruck, dass so ein bisschen diese ganze Netzbewegung so dabei ist, sich ein weiteres Mal neu zu finden. So in den letzten 10, 20 Jahren war alles sehr geprägt von wenigen sehr sichtbaren Akteuren. Deutschland, aber auch weltweit große starke Gruppen, die sich zusammengefunden haben, sei es der CCC, sei es IFF etc. Jetzt ist so der Playground hat sich irgendwie so ein bisschen vergrößert. Viele Leute drängen nach, sind eigentlich auch erst mal so ein bisschen heimatlos und denen fehlen auch so ein bisschen die Orientierung auf der einen Seite, aber vielleicht auch einfach so ein bisschen schlicht auch einfach nur die Erfahrung. Es ist halt einfach wiederum mal sehr früh. Es ist so ein bisschen so wie auch mit dem Internet als solchen. Man hatte so am Anfang so das Netz, da waren dann so die ganzen Alteingesessenen, die da schon sehr lange dabei waren, so lang ging das gut. Und dann gab es so diese Phase ab 1995, wo man immer das Gefühl hatte, und in gewisser Hinsicht war es wahrscheinlich auch so, dass jeden Tag mehr Leute neu dazukamen, als es vorher insgesamt in dem ganzen Netz gab. Das ist einer meiner Lieblingssprüche aus der Internet-Historie, der immer wieder hervorgeholt werden kann. Jetzt mache ich es auch gleich nochmal, dieses Imminent Death of the Net Predicted, wo die Allgemeinen gesagt haben, oh Gott, jetzt kommen hier die ganzen Newbies, alles wird jetzt niedergerissen, wofür wir ewig gearbeitet haben, everything is doomed und morgen ist das Internet tot. Und was passiert, ist natürlich was anderes. Und in gewisser Hinsicht ist es, was jetzt diesen Aktivismus betrifft, auch so ein bisschen ähnlich. Auf einmal diese Angst vor Anonymous, wenn jetzt die Kiddies weiterhin nur Sitzblockaden, Digitale machen und dann versuchen, alles niederzureißen, was ihnen jetzt gerade mal nicht in Kram passt, hat man ja auch das Problem, dass das eine Gegenbewegung schnell erzeugt. Es gibt ja dann auch gleich diese Abwehrreaktionen. Das sind ja dann alles Terroristen und dann muss man die auch entsprechend alle behandeln. Dann werden dann so einzelne rausgeprägt und abgestraft, um mal ein Exempel zu setzen etc. Ich glaube, in Holland ist sowas ja passiert mit Anonymous.
Und in den UK, glaube ich.
Also in verschiedenen Fällen. Dass das natürlich am Ende nicht viel Auswirkungen haben wird, ist uns, glaube ich, trefflich bewusst. Aber ich glaube, was so ein bisschen fehlt, sind so Design-Patterns. Wo sich Erfahrung so ein bisschen abstrakt widerspiegelt. Wie baue ich das auf? Was du auch schon teilweise so gesagt hast. Nicht allein dieser Aspekt psychologische Betreuung, und Reflektion der Arbeit.
Ja, also ich glaube ja, dass wir, dass die Gruppen, die es gibt, es hervorragend geschafft haben, Menschen abzuschrecken. Also ich habe jetzt nach Jahren irgendwie das erste Mal kein Problem, mich in einem Chaos-Computer-Club treffen zu bewegen. Das erste Mal fühle ich mich nicht dumm angeguckt. Weil? Ja, leider kennen mich halt teilweise die Leute einfach auch aus Funk und Fernsehen und von Märchenkassetten.
Hey, du bist doch der aus dem Fernsehen.
Genau, du bist doch der aus dem Podcast da, du bist doch der aus dem Chaos-Radio. Ja, da ist eine gewisse Credibility jetzt da, jetzt funktioniert das. Als ich vor ein paar Jahren zum ersten Mal in einem Airfar auftauchte, im Rhein-Main-Gebiet, das waren so die Orgwaters 10 minutes of my life, bis ich wieder gegangen bin einfach. Also die Gruppen, die es momentan gibt, sind nicht offen. Also sie weigern, sie wollen doch gar nicht offen sein. Der Anspruch ist gar nicht da. Aber ja, sie lernen gerade alle bei Anonymous. Wie mache ich das, wie mache ich das mit den Gruppen? Wir haben ja Telecomix einen anderen Weg gehabt. Vielleicht, weil es einen anderen Ursprung hatte. Aber im Endeffekt, die Gruppen, die es gibt, also auch die ganzen Arbeitskreise, AK-Vorrat, AK-Censur, das sind keine offen strukturierten Gruppen. Die laden dich nicht ein, mitzuarbeiten. Sie laden dich ein, dich tot zu diskutieren, aber nicht zu arbeiten oder irgendwie zu gestalten. CCC ist für mich, finde ich, auch eine sehr geschlossene Gruppe. Wenn man nicht schon irgendwie ganz viel kann, kann man nicht dazu. Was ich sehr schade finde, weil es gibt großartige Airfaser draußen. Gut, dann die ganzen großen Gruppen wie EFF und E3. Das sind ja eh geschlossene Gruppen im Endeffekt schon vom Design her geschlossen, weil es ja Gruppen von Gruppen sind. Wo sollen sie denn hin? Da ist nicht viel. Und bei Telecomix haben wir nicht die Ressourcen, Leute zu integrieren. Das können wir gar nicht leisten. Aber wenn wir das alle integrieren könnten, die sich angeboten haben, hätten wir jetzt irgendwie 1000 Leute. Ist natürlich nicht. Da ist natürlich auch keiner, der den Jungen, dem Nachwuchs sagt, hey, das kann man so machen. Vielleicht ist da aber auch noch ein anderer Weg. Aber wir können es ja mal zusammensetzen, uns einfach mal durchexerzieren, mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt. Ja, wir ermuntern ganz viele junge Leute, sich mit Technik zu beschäftigen. Aber wir ermuntern sie nicht mit dieser Technik, die sie erlernt haben, ihre Umwelt zu gestalten, im Sinne von das Netz gestalten. Wir ermuntern sie dazu, irgendwie Quattrocopter zu bauen, was geil ist. Aber wir ermuntern sie nicht dazu, für das Netz, das wir alle lieben, mit die Verantwortung zu übernehmen. Nehmen wir halt einfach dann die Dinge tun, die wir für richtig halten. Das passiert nicht. Ja, Kinder von der Datenstraße holen, genau. Das ist also mein Eindruck, den ich jetzt auch in den letzten Jahren befestigt habe bei mir. Es ist unglaublich schwer, in die bestehende Gruppierung rein zu geraten.
Aber ich denke, das ist auch ein Teil einer... Bisher war es immer sehr überschaubar. Das ist jetzt eine neue Situation, dass es für viele mehr Leute eine Selbstverständlichkeit ist. Ich denke, auch mit der Piratenpartei hat sich etwas Ähnliches abgezeichnet, wo auch viele Leute auf einmal unter dem Tisch vollgekrochen gekommen sind, die gesagt haben, es gibt da mal wieder einen neuen Player. Da kann man dann halt einfach so Mitglied werden. Man ist halt dabei. Vielleicht ist das ja was für mich. Da drückt sich schon aus, dass wir es jetzt mit einer, nicht wahrscheinlich nicht mal nur mit einer, sondern vielleicht sogar schon zwei Generationen oder drei von Leuten zu tun haben, die dieses Thema jetzt einfach auch für sich neu entdecken. Also gar nicht immer nur die Jungen, sondern vielleicht auch schon die 30-Jährigen, die jetzt so durch ihre Ausbildung durchmarschiert sind und die jetzt auf einmal sehen so, oh holla, jetzt komme ich so langsam in dieses Alter, wo man eigentlich auch anfängt, in dieser Gesellschaft was zu bewirken und nicht nur so ein Zaungast zu sein. Und jetzt darf ich auch mal wählen und so. Und jetzt muss ich aber hier erstmal durch den Ausbildungsacker und ich bin jetzt erstmal gar nichts wert. Aber dann irgendwann hast du dann eben deine Ausbildung, hast du da irgendwie deinen Beruf angetreten, bist du vielleicht auch sowieso schon politisch tätig oder merkst auch einfach grundsätzlich, dass wenn du 30 wirst, dass die Leute anfangen, dich auf einmal einfach so ernst zu nehmen.
Unglaublich.
Einfach so, weil man 30 ist. Weil dann irgendwie alle davon ausgehen, ok, alles klar, jetzt hast du irgendwie so deine Twin-Phase ja hinter dir, jetzt glauben wir dir auch vielleicht mal was zu sagen.
Deswegen hab ich mir die Haare blau zu färben, als ich 30 wurde.
Hast du angefangen?
Ja.
Willst du Kind bleiben?
In gewisser Weise ja. Ja, das gehört auch damit rein. Aber ich war genau dieses mit 30 plötzlich ernst. Und mit 30 und dem Anzug bin ich übrigens richtig ernst.
Das ist stark.
Und 40. Da geht es erst richtig los. Und das fand ich immer irgendwie doof, dieses Konzept.
An der Stelle, gut, aber das passiert so. Und ich denke, das ist einfach so eine Phase, wo sich einfach so eine Generation von potentiellen Aktivisten, ob sie es alle werden, will ich gar nicht sagen, da einfach neu finden muss und sich einfach neue Gruppen und Strukturen zwangsläufig herausbilden.
Ja, das.
Und natürlich auch gegen die etablierten Alten ein bisschen anstinken müssen, um sich einfach auch ihr Gehör zu verschaffen.
Genau. Und ich finde es ja auch spannend, zusätzlich noch, dass sich ganz viele neue Gruppen bilden. Es gibt eine Art neues Phantom da draußen. Also ich erlebe das immer wieder, wie Menschen Jacob Applebaum anhimmeln, der ja auch irgendwie ein Rockstar und ein Aktivist ist.
Ja.
Wir brauchen eh mehr für Rockstars und Aktivisten, die einfach irgendwie smart wirken, eloquent reden können, also schonmal nicht ich. Und irgendwie halt, also nicht nur was zu sagen, sondern auch was darstellen, was man auch irgendwie gerne sehen mag, das Bild, dass man das da erscheint. Plötzlich werden halt...
Role Models.
Ja, Role Models, genau. Und halt irgendwie auch ja Rockstars, wie gesagt, das brauchen wir glaube ich schon in der Aktivisten-Szene ein bisschen mehr. Einfach weil einfach zu zeigen, so hey, wir sind coole Säue, weil wir sind coole Säue. Und wir vergessen es uns ganz regelmäßig oft selbst zu sagen. Und ich meine schon, Holland war eine coole Sau. Ja, das hat da irgendwie angefangen mit den coolen Säuen. Und deswegen gab es immer wieder alle paar Jahre irgendwie jemand, der echt eigentlich so ein Star hätte sein können.
Ja.
Also auch außerhalb dieser Nerd-Szene.
Na die einfach die Gaber haben dann auch einfach so die Öffentlichkeit auf sich einpressen zu lassen. Man muss auch glaube ich ab einem bestimmten Punkt dann auch einfach lernen mit der Öffentlichkeit umzugehen. Ich meine, das ist auch etwas, was gewisser Hinsicht, gerade wenn man so im CCC groß geworden ist, da ist es eben auch so ein Teil der Kultur, dieses Spiel mit der Öffentlichkeit auch zu lernen. Und wenn es nur irgendwie mit der Presse reden ist, aber auch generell Veranstaltungen machen. Das ist schon dieser Urknall mit diesem BTX-Hack und wie das in die Medien getragen worden ist. Das hat einem einfach schon eine ganze Menge dazu beigetragen, wie so das Selbstverständnis ist. Und dass eben auch das Hacken als solches, was ja irgendwie im Kern immer das Beeinflussen der Gesellschaft zum Ziel hatte, dass das eben auch selbst eine eigene Hackdisziplin ist. Dass das genauso, wie man mit Systemen klarkommt, wie man Programme schreibt, wie man Büchsen aufmacht, wie man irgendwie an Protokolle von Firmwares anderer Länder herankommt, dass eigentlich auch dieses Social-Engineering und dieses nach außen abstrahlen einfach genauso dazugehört und einfach so ein Werkzeug ist, den man sich annehmen muss und wo es dann auch ja eigentlich blöd ist, wenn man dann selber immer sagt, naja ach nee, hier irgendwie zu vielen Leuten reden und so.
Ich stimme dir vollkommen zu. Man wird aber auch, wenn man irgendwie plötzlich außerkorn ist in einer Gruppe mit den Medien zu sprechen, es nervt schon irgendwann. Was aber auch einfach daran liegt, dass man selten was Neues erzählt. Das ist jetzt heute eins der wenigen Male, wo ich wieder was Neues erzählen kann, was mich sehr freut. Und wir haben es auch geschafft, in den letzten Jahren eine Abneigung gegen Medien zu produzieren. Die Totholz-Medien, die schreiben eh nur alles falsch auf, die zitieren die nicht richtig. Ja, natürlich zitieren sie mich nicht richtig. Weil sie müssen auch verkaufen. Ja, wenn die Geschichte spannend ist, zitieren sie mich richtig. Also, wenn die Geschichte, die ich erzähle, gut ist und sie gut erzählt ist, wird sie auch richtig wiedergegeben. Und das funktioniert. Also, ich habe jetzt noch nichts grob fahrlässig falsches an Zitaten von mir gefunden. Wahrscheinlich ist die Geschichte spannend genug, um sie so zu erzählen.
Oder spannend genug erzählt.
Oder auch spannend genug erzählt. Und ja, das ist halt, aber ich gucke auch meine Gegenüber, wenn ich mich rede, an. Ich habe andere Nerds gesehen, wenn sie in der Presse gesprochen haben. Das war halt die bebende Unsicherheit. Das ist halt auch das, was ich auch nach wie vor glaube, ist, dass wir in unseren Nerdkreisen viel mehr Sozialkompetenzen vermitteln müssen irgendwie. Ich glaube, das ist etwas, was wir wirklich tun müssen. Als Community, als Szene, weil sonst werden diese Menschen irgendwie gerade diese Sachen nicht machen können, irgendwie geile Geschichte erzählen, was sie gerade gerissen haben. Und irgendwie halt den Fame wirklich dann nicht nur aus den Kreisen abzukriegen, sondern auch nach außen zu zeigen, wir sind ganz normale Leute und wir machen halt Technologie und wir können das halt. Wir haben Spaß und dafür machen wir halt auch richtig geile Sachen. Und das kannst du übrigens auch, weil das ist ja nicht das, was wir wollen. Wir wollen den Leuten sagen, das kannst du auch. Du musst halt dafür was lernen, aber hey, das ist geil. Und das kannst du auch erzählen. Hab ich schon lange nicht mehr gehört bei Nerds. Gegenüber Nicht-Nerds. Und auch das Neugierig machen auf die Dinge, die wir tun. Ist in den letzten Jahren mit alles Acht nach Vier auf der Strecke geblieben. Wir haben Kongress, kommt immer wieder kurz in den Zeitungen, was für geile Sachen da passieren. Aber auch immer so ein bisschen das Tanz dabei. Wir haben Camp das Gleiche. Es war schon cool, was wir gemacht haben auf dem Camp. Aber es sind ja doch die Nerds und Geeks. Also auch diese Tanz dahinter. Und die möchte ich, also das würde ich mir wünschen, dass das hier eingebrochen ist. Dass eben diese Tanz nicht mehr da ist. Auch von den Medien und von den Leuten nicht mehr. Weil dieses Medienbild prägt auch unser Bild bei den normalen Leuten da draußen, die halt nicht die Aktivisten, nicht die Nerds, und nicht die Hacker. Und das ist halt immer so... Dann gibt es auch wiederum andere Seiten. Die wollen es ja genauso. Die wollen ja dieses Erhaben vom Rest. Und das fand ich sehr spannend. Das ist letztes Jahr, Kongress-Motto war We Come In Peace, fand ich sehr großartig. Wir sind die Aliens, die in Frieden kommen. Und dieses Jahr Behind Enemy Lines, fand ich ziemlich heftig. Das ist schon so ein bisschen... Ihr seid der Feind. Also das ist erst mal nur, wenn man nur das Motto so liest. Das ist so die erste Assoziation.
Ich bin ein großer Freund des Motto. Ich bin sehr zufrieden mit dem Motto. Weil es ist eigentlich ein bester CCC-Kultur doppeldeutig zu sehen. Das kann man so sehen. Es ist aber tatsächlich auch eine Zustandsbeschreibung. Du bist Teil davon, weißt du? Weil du bist behind enemy lines gewesen. Das ist auch das, was es ausmacht. Das ist einfach auch eine Feststellung der Realität. Das ist einfach das, was gerade passiert. Man befindet sich einfach auf einmal abgeworfen mit dem digitalen Fallschirm. Im feinen Land. Im feindlichen Territorium. Und das ist mit Wikileaks und mit vielen anderen Sachen, mit Trojanern etc. Einfach das Thema. Und ich denke, das ist einfach das Thema, was dort aufgegriffen werden wird. Das ist nicht unbedingt jetzt die eigentliche Botschaft, dass man da sein sollte.
Ich denke auch, dass das aufgegriffen wird auf dem Kongress. Aber wenn ich jetzt so als Nicht-Nerd, ob der ganze Dinge weiß, das Motto lese, ist die erste Implikation, die sehen mich als Feind an. Das ist so was.
Wirklich? Das kann ich jetzt so nicht nachvollziehen, aber ich denke, das wird sich dann auch erklären. Da gab es noch ganz andere Motto, die man hätte falsch versteht. Aber gut, nichtsdestotrotz, wir haben jetzt, glaube ich, ganz gut umrissen. Es ist auf jeden Fall was in Bewegung. Telecomix hat auch gezeigt, es bedarf eigentlich nicht viel mehr, als eine halbwegs ausgeprägten Kompetenz gepaart mit einem Willen auch wirklich was zu verändern. Es gibt genug Möglichkeiten, was zu machen. Man muss sich jetzt nicht unbedingt in irgendetwas Etabliertes einklinken. Aber es ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen der Bedarf sichtbar geworden, dass man eben mal schauen muss, was hat man eigentlich bisher so gelernt aus dem Aktivismus? Was sind so die goldenen Regeln? Was sind so die Erfahrungswerte, die getauscht werden müssen? Vielleicht schreibt ja mal jemand solche Design-Patterns auf, wäre mal ganz interessant, um einfach da auch noch mehr Gerüst entstehen zu lassen und auch vielleicht andere Spielarten des Widerstands und der proaktiven Netzkultur da gebären zu lassen, die wir jetzt eben so noch nicht sehen können. Weil es ist nicht unbedingt immer alles nur dieses Schlechtfinden und Niedermachen und dagegen sein und das irgendwie zu zementieren. Es bedarf halt auch so einer kreativen Komponente, die halt versucht, eben auch mitzugestalten. Weil ich denke, über kurz oder lang, das sieht man jetzt auch in Deutschland, ob die Piratenpartei jetzt da schon die Instanz ist, das sei mal dahingestellt, aber ein Teil der Gesellschaft hat einfach jetzt auch erkannt, okay, wir leben jetzt im Informationszeitalter, da stellen sich neue Fragen und wir sollen bitte schön die Antworten liefern, wenn nicht die Leute, die damit groß geworden sind. Und ich denke, dass es eben auch, dass wir schon, vielleicht noch nicht darüber hinaus, aber wir sind zumindest an diesem Punkt angekommen, wo auf der vermeintlichen Gegenseite eigentlich nur noch große Fragezeichen sind, die einfach auch mal mit Antworten beliefert werden wollen, dass es durchaus auch vielleicht eine Bereitschaft gibt, da was zu gestalten, wenn sie denn, und auch an der Stelle fehlt eben auch wieder diese Orientierung, da eben auch entsprechende Partner haben, mit denen man eben was machen kann und die jetzt eben nicht nur anfangen, irgendwie die Bundestagsverwaltung runterzufahren oder sowas, weil sie mal wieder mit irgendeinem Gesetz nicht so glücklich geworden sind. Das steht ja alles zu befürchten.
Ja, Tim.
Ich glaube, jetzt haben wir es ganz gut hier durchgeweigt, das Thema. War mal echt eine schöne philosophische Debatte. Und vor allem auch ein schöner Einblick in die Arbeit von Telecomix. Interessantes Projekt, was eine Menge Welle gemacht hat und noch dabei ist, Welle zu machen. Zu diesem Zeitpunkt ist überhaupt noch nicht absehbar, wie das in Syrien weitergeht.
Oder sonst wo auf der Welt.
Oder auch Bahrain oder eben sonst wo auf der Welt. Ich denke, es gibt noch so einige andere Kandidaten, auch in Europa, die durchaus demnächst mal einen ähnlichen Bedarf haben könnten. Und vielleicht ist es das ja auch, was am Ende das kleine Schmetterlings-Flügelschlag ist, der dann die Kacke zum Überlaufen bringen lässt. Vielen Dank für die Ausführung hier bei CAE und vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Hier geht es bald weiter.